thank you yes
welcome everyone to this afternoon's
planning committee meeting before we
start i would like to confirm which
committee members and officers are here
thank you chair so joining us uh
remotely for this meeting
are councillors william armitage
jane barry
andrew cooper peter elliott
mark foster carol huckabee
mo potts allen powell
tracy weider
jackie ridgway kathy rouse
diana ruff
and ross shipman also in the meeting
room is uh councillor barry lewis who's
speaking today as a ward member
we have members of the planning team
alice lockett phil slater and emily
cartwright jim fieldsend is joining us
from the legal team and my i'm nicola
calvar i'm the governance manager i will
facilitate this meeting and also on the
call are alan damon martin
and naomi from the governance team to
support this meeting thank you chair
thank you
as you know we have a protocol in place
for a meeting in this virtual way which
i would now like the meeting facilitator
to read out
thank you chair so this is just a
reminder to all members of the committee
to dress and behave during this meeting
as if you would do if you were in the
council chamber at mill lane please be
aware the meeting is being streamed and
i'm just about to press the record
button to ensure that this meeting is
recorded for the purpose of minute
taking you'll hear announcement just
shortly over the stream this meeting is
being recorded
a reminder to all members to speak
through the chair this means that you'll
need to remain muted throughout the
throughout the meeting um to also to
keep your camera on you can use the chat
function to request to speak at any time
and alternatively you can raise your
hand the chair should be able to see you
but if not i will be assisting the chair
to help her to be able to see all
members should they wish to speak
a reminder for all members when they are
wishing to speak to introduce yourself
and just say say
council x representing y ward so that
the members of the public who are
viewing this and participating in the
meeting are
know who you are
we will be doing voting during this
meeting by roll call
on every application
please just be mindful of your home
surroundings and appear alone when
you're on camera
and just that final reminder to keep
your camera on throughout the meeting we
understand that counselor eliot is
having some technical issues today if he
does turn off his camera it's to do with
his wi-fi thank you chair
thank you
the first item on today's agenda is
apologies for absence have we received
any in advance
general apologies for absence have been
received
and are there any other apologies
chair all the members are present
thank you
the second item is declaration of
interest members are requested to
declare the existence and nature of any
disposable pecuniary interest and or
other interests not already on their
register of interests in any item on the
agenda and withdraw from the meeting at
the appropriate time
have we received any declarations in
advance
uh council tracy reed is indicating she
wishes to speak yeah
thank you councillor reader
uh i need to declare an interest in ned
20 000 221 the clay cross application
and chair i will be speaking as a ward
member on this application and i will
leave the meeting at the appropriate
time
thank you
minutes of the last meeting we now have
the minutes of our meeting held on
tuesday the 17th of november 2020
are we happy that they are a correct
record
is there a mover
move it uh
got councillor powell and armitage on
this one sure
thank you very much is everyone in
agreement with this
thank you
that moves us onto the main business
today and as you can see we have four
applications each of which has its own
report marked as items 4a to 4d
i am happy with this and intend to
consider them in that order
however before we do this i would like
the clerk to explain for the benefit of
members speakers and the public who are
watching on youtube how they will be
dealt with
right uh thank you chair
uh this is the procedure for considering
applications at the meeting
we will consider the four applications
in the order that they are set out on
the agenda
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers planning
officers rather to refer members to any
late comments or updates received since
the agenda was issued
the late items agenda supplement has
been published on the council's website
and the link has been sent to committee
members
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
the screen showing this presentation
will be shared with those attending the
meeting
they can also be seen on the council's
website through its youtube channel
following on from this
the chair will ask each of the speakers
any ward members first followed by
objectors then the applicant or their
agent
to speak to the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views using the
conferencing facility
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes
members of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary in order to clarify any
points that they have made
when we have heard from all of the
speakers on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee
and determination by a vote
now a note here for the speakers
once the application you've come to
speak on has been dealt with you may
leave the virtual meeting room
if you choose to remain
then please mute your microphone and
turn off your camera
you will not be allowed to participate
further in the meeting from that point
as you are aware
this meeting is being live streamed
the council will make a recording for
the purposes of preparing the minutes
once the minutes have been approved by
the committee
then this recording will be deleted
but please note that others may decide
to record the live stream from the
internet
thank you chair
thank you
before we move on to the first item i'm
just going to let you know as we've got
four applications this afternoon we are
factoring in a short break
and we're sort of aiming this to be
around about the three o'clock time
limit
so it may be sooner and it may be
slightly afterwards but that's what
we're aiming for thank you
move on to the first application
and this is the residential development
of 34 dwellings associated
infrastructure and land opposite 24 to
44 clay lane clay cross
believe
this is going to be heard by
phil slater the officer
if you'd like to do a presentation be
there somewhere yes thank you chair
when you're ready
just waiting for the presentation to
come on screen all right suspected would
you like me to do that for you yes yes
please thanks nikki
that's great just have the first slide
please nikki
thank you chair
first i'll refer members to the late
comments report which includes a number
of objections from residents i would
also refer members to the comments from
the applicant's ecologist in respect to
the three sites for off-site mitigation
the three sites show a net gain in
biodiversity to compensate for the
losses on site
as set out in the report the site falls
outside of the settlement development
limits for clay cross in the adopted
local plan the scientists however
proposed housing allocation in the
emerging local plan and is considered to
be broadly sustainable
the development is for 34 dwellings
including bungalows and 20 affordable
housing will be provided
along with section 106 contributions to
secondary education off-site play
provision and off-site biodiversity
enhancement
this slide shows the application site in
the center with clay lane to the south
open fields to the north
the east is the press brook and rear
gardens are properties on windermere
road
to the west is an area of trees some of
which have already been removed the site
generally slopes from east to west
towards the brook for the next slide
please
thank you
this shows the red line application site
boundary
the next
west under windermere road
in the eastern corner are a group of
trees which are the former orchard and
proposals are to train retain parts of
this area and enhance with fruit trees
native tree and shrub planting
to the south lies clay lane and existing
properties on the opposite side of the
road
and to the north is open fields and
further north lies kenning park
at the next slide please
this slide shows on the left the site
within the adopted local plan which lies
in countryside and outside of the
settled development limits
the slide on the right shows the
proposed allocation for housing in the
emerging local plan and the settlement
redrawn around the site the proposed
allocation is for an estimated 25
dwellings
next slide please
this slide shows this shows that the
site lies within flood zone 1 however
properties to the
west on windermere road are at a lower
level than the site and lie within flood
zones two and three
the lead local flood authority have not
objected and have recommended conditions
19 to 22 in the report which include
details of maintenance of the brook
the next slide please
this slide shows a proposed slight
layout for 34 dwellings which are a mix
of two three and four bed dwellings
including bungalows and a 20
affordable housing which equates to
seven units
the layout is outward facing onto clay
lane with a single point of access off
clay lane
on the site boundary is the air vent to
the clay cross tunnel which is a feature
of the site along with a footpath which
is proposed along the frontage to run
through to the orchard and a public
footpath
in the southwest corner to the bottom
right of the screen are the affordable
units that front onto clay lane along
with a footpath link which is also
proposing this corner
car parking for these units is shown to
the rear and off the turning head
in the eastern part of the site is an
area of trees to be retained and
enhanced as an orchard
i say a number of these trees have
already been removed however they are
not subject to a tree preservation order
the northern boundary which is the
left-hand side of the screen faces
outwards onto the fields and the
bungalows propose along this edge
to the west at the bottom of the plan
lies the press brook watercourse and
opposite to the rear gardens of
properties on windermere road
trees will be retained on the bank to
form a buffer to allow for the
maintenance of both the brook and for
the otters condition 13 relates to an
after mitigation strategy
the next slide please
this slide shows the landscape master
plan trees along the brook are to be
retained and trees in the eastern corner
would form the heritage orchard
additional planting is shown within the
development and the new hedgerow to the
frontage with clay lane
as referred to in the late comments
report the loss of biodiversity will be
compensated for on three off-site
locations which would demonstrate a
net gain in biodiversity
at the next life please
this is the tree removal and retention
plan there is in red what are the trees
which are to be removed
along with the hedgerow which fronts
onto clay lane
trees to be retained along the eastern
northern and western boundaries are also
shown
thank you
the top picture is the street scene
which fronts onto clay lane and shows
the air vent in the center
the access is to the right
and the three units on the far left are
the affordable units
the bottom picture shows the bungalows
on the northern boundary with the fields
thank you
this is two example house types
next thank you and
uh two examples of semi-detached houses
with the affordable units to the left
this is a photo taken from this south
west corner looking north the trees on
the left line the bank of the brook
windermere road lies beyond these trees
this is a view looking south back
towards clay lane the trees on the right
are on the back of the brook the rear
gardens of windermere road can be seen
at a lower ground level than the side
this is a view of the brook with the
rear guard overhead opposite bank
another view of the brook application
site is to the left and these trees are
proposed to be retained
just two photos taken looking
approximately northeast towards the
church by a left-hand photo was taken
last week and right up photos taken
during the summer top right is the area
of trees that form the orchard
it's photo
looking east
cheese in the center of screen the
tunnel vent can be seen in the top right
as can be seen from this photo the land
slopes down towards the brook
thank you
again two photos he's taken from the
southwest corner site looking east on
the right is a hedgerow that fronts onto
the clay lane and is proposed to be
removed as part of the development
this is a photo of the northern boundary
of the site you can just see the the
church spa on the left-hand side
it's photo taken from the northern
boundary looking back towards clay lane
on the air vent
the opposed access will be to the left
of the vent
this is a view looking north east
towards the trees in the eastern part of
the site
it's another view back towards the
northeast corner
uh the tree in the center is supposed to
be moved as part of the development
it's a view back towards clay lane with
the trees on the left
this view is taken outside the site from
the footpath looking south west towards
the site
trees along the brook can be seen in the
bottom right hand side of the photo
if you're looking down clay lane towards
the proposed access and the air vent the
access is approximately where the white
placard sign is
it's another view down clay lane
so view the air vent and the field gate
marks proposed site access
so if you're looking back up clay lane
opposite the access
view further down clay lane the hedge on
the opposite side is one supposed to be
removed
that's a view back up clay lane left is
the approximate location of the
affordable units which would front onto
clay lane
that's the end of the presentation thank
you chair
thank you
are there any points of clarification
required at this point
councillor armitage councillor rouse
yeah it's to do with the
why do we need to take the uh uh
the hedge out uh that prompts the uh
you know where the uh affordable houses
are and is the uh
uh
the air vent uh is it to uh a pitch
shaft or a railway line and is it active
uh with regards to the air vent it's to
the clay cross tunnel
right so exactly
yes okay
right
the trees
well well the issue of the trees and the
hedgerows is is covered within within
the report um
through the chow is that not for
questions
questions for officers later perhaps yes
okay
thank you councillor rose
yes um cathy ross councillor house of
the play cross north um i think for me
i'll probably have to ask the question
later um because i want to know because
i don't live too far from this
why is the land
been cleared before
any agreements been made as to whether
we give permission or not permission
again chad i would have thought that
would be for questions
later
thank you
okay
any other points for clarification
before we move on
i should move on to now asking the
speakers to speak and we have the first
speaker is councillor tracy reeder she's
a ward member
uh i think
council shipman was indicating oh sorry
for me sorry
councillor shipman sorry cherry just
something that came to me last minute um
menu is giving you presentation phillip
the um you mentioned i saw on one of the
slides that the application was for 25.
i'm drawing my paper say 35.
can you just clarify which one yeah
no it was it was to point out that the
proposed allocation within the local
plan is for an estimated 25 dwellings
this is okay
okay
before we move on is there any chance of
the volume being turned up in here we
can barely hear
i'll just come along now chair thank you
okay
counselor reader if you'd like to start
thank you chair thank you for allowing
me to speak on this application today i
want to urge the committee to listen to
the residents surrounding this
development and oppose this application
the reasons i request that this
committee reject the application is that
the site is with uh is outside the
settlement limit of the current local
plan i'm aware that the emerging local
plan is not yet completed and therefore
even though it's a very advanced stage
i'd urge the committee to apply the
current arrangements
within the emerging local plan the site
has been identified as a potential site
for 25 homes and this application is for
34 and as pointed out by the parish
council will potentially create an issue
with a piece of land that fronts onto
clay lane and are joined adjacent to
footpath 13.
i also don't believe that the 20
of affordable homes is enough
and with current climate at the moment i
think that clay cross people locally
would find it extremely difficult to
afford homes
i draw your attention to the comments
submitted by clay cross parish council
colleagues of which i fully conquer
i and the parish council have concerns
with regards to the potential loss of
heritage value and the historical links
contained within this site i would ask
the committee that they place weight on
and preserve some of clay crosses
valuable history with regards to the uh
grade two listed air vent that's located
within this site and is associated with
quakers tunnel
i would argue that to complete the
housing development around this would be
tracked and distract away from
craig cross's valuable history
in terms of flooding which has been a
concern for many years on this site
the nearby pressbrook has always been a
problem
the area is known to have flooded at
least four times in the last few few
years and i'm sure that the committee
have heard from residents regarding
their experiences of the flooding in
this area
i'm sure they've shared lots of pictures
and things with you
um
i also believe that building on this
site would exacerbate the problems
for residents on nearby windermere road
and i also believe it would increase
flooding to other areas and neighboring
streets and the lower area of clay clay
lane
50 seconds remain
okay
i and the parish council feel that
building on this site has the potential
to adversely impact on other nearby
sites including kenny park
and saint bartholomew's church which is
located just up the road
cross is very keen to have a really rich
biodiversity
and declared a climate change emergency
last year and we really would like to
have more areas of untouched
uh
green space in which wildlife can really
thrive and this area has got its own
share of biodiversity i don't know
that's three minutes oh thank you sorry
i hope the president can kind of give
more are there any questions for
councillor rita
no thank you thank you councillor thank
you
our next speaker is mandy bingham
hello
hello mandy you have three minutes
starting when you're ready
all right i'd just like to say that clay
lane isn't is just a lane it measures
4.3 metres at nares creating bottlenecks
and four point nine meters across from
the proposed entrance site it also has a
7.5 ton weight limit it's inadequate to
sustain any further traffic and cannot
cope with traffic that's on there now
and it also has a problem with parked
cars which
limits parking spaces
it's unable you're unable to see past it
and once you're committed you're on that
right way whether it's your right way or
not you you're
substantial in oncoming traffic
limited parking on the site itself is
meaning that they only align 1.5 spaces
per dwelling which is less than
northeast alberta's recommendations
would um impact on
our way safety by forcing more park
traffic onto there
and making it very um
very unsafe
um
and also i think everybody's
underestimated the fact about how many
people actually use cars and car
ownership which is against national
planning price framework and it's also
been investigated a clay cross 2020
regeneration framework where they found
out that 88 local people already
travelled by a car
um and that breaches national planning
policy framework where it says it's
failed in access and development on
car ownership
um
there's also been a refuge what i'm an
analyst done and it shows that the
dustbin wagon itself would contravene
white lines by at least 500 ml
but on also on photographs that's
already been shown by philip slater just
which shows the lane being just a lane
and one of the bends it show shows that
the vehicle the dustbin vehicle turning
left out of that hose development side
would actually have to
either contravene and go onto the
pavement or go up clay lane
on the wrong side of the road into
oncoming traffic by at least 50 meters
not returning to its same site it's
proposed after the carriageway until
opposite i think it's number 20 on clay
lane
and also the plans
visibility display 2.4 by 43 is totally
unachievable when turning right
and it would also cause um
a concealed entrance for traffic to
coming off the clay lane
up towards um
the development itself
meaning that
with the um
[Music]
the tunnel uh the air shaft being where
it is it only leaves actual visibility
of 21 meters which does not allow for
the stopping distance of 23 meters
and unless the plans have been drawn by
somebody that feels that everybody can
actually three minutes chair
okay
are you having problems chair
sorry the next speaker for nella jones
good afternoon everybody
just before that was were there any
questions to the previous speaker
i oh sorry did that not come across
uh sorry claire now yeah it did i missed
it
i take that members i've got no
questions no thank you sorry sure
if you'd like to start vanilla when
you're ready you have three minutes
okay thank you very much um
so my name is ben jones and i live at
number 34 clay lane i've lived here
since 1988 and in 2000 we bought the
house next door come both both houses to
one
to
make the house suitable for our growing
family to put things in perspective our
house is directly opposite the tunnel
vent that has been shown in all the
previous photographs shown by hunting
officer mr slater
when we bought this house there was no
provision for any building on the lamp
field opposite
and the only proposals there were in 74
and 76 for one dwelling which were both
refused
for obviously very good reasons
this local plan states that this
development should be reduced from 42 to
25 properties based on the council
standard density calculation so my first
question is why are we even considering
the proposal of 34 houses
currently clay cross has two large
developments taking place which will
create over a thousand new homes
uh since modern and avent on um by the
bible site are in addition to other
large developments on the a61 corridor
currently being developed by keir
bellway and taylor wimpy or within north
historical district and this is
excluding all the developments of the
north of the district at dronfield and
eckington
i object object to this proposal
based on the following grounds traffic
and access to the site for 34 houses
as mandy has just stated um most of the
um access
considerations um have been a little bit
um shall we say perhaps understated in
the planning officer's um
proper presentation
i would like to see that um a proper
evaluation of
the traffic for this this site be taken
out i understand that their highways
have only done a desktop analysis on
this due to covid i think it now
warrants something a bit more um
substantial in terms of actually having
a look as to how narrow this lane is
access the services and infrastructure
the level of housing housing building
house building in this area is already
at a high and any further house building
will only put extra strain on existing
services such as health and schools
whilst the new primary school for
wingers has been proposed there is
nothing to say what extra provision for
secondary school education will be made
so
i i can't see the
the merit in 30 seconds remaining thank
you
so i must also like to say um that
the the environmental issues um which
have been
touched on flooding noise pollution
um
all have
an impact on on habitat and i think the
merit that the planning officer alluded
to
perhaps is not correct
that's three minutes
okay thank you thank you thank you very
much have we any questions for the
speaker
thank you very much
our next speaker is richard barr
hello
hello
hello
we can hear you we can't see you
mr parker is joining us my telephone
channel okay
mr barry
you have three minutes
right
main objections are in relation to
what's been mentioned overlooking
um it's been mentioned that the trees on
the river bank at pres brook act as a
buffet
well if you want to come and have a look
at this time of year they do offer some
uh
affordability some of some uh cover
during the summer months when they're in
leaf well currently after leaf fall
it's a it's a straight view on the site
which is elevated from windermere road
uh
directly into our our properties
we make which makes you look like you're
in a fishbowl yeah
so that's one of the issues and is
anything going to be considered in
relation to adding to that buffer um in
relation to to cover that point
and what the main issue is in relation
to what's been mentioned is it flooding
now press brook itself turns into smithy
brook under the uh road bridge
and if
anybody cares to take a walk down mill
lane and look at the state of the river
down there where there's at least three
trees what's strong to the uh river
and are acting as obs obstructions to
the flow
and any sort of rubbish or leaves what
fall down there
leaf fall it gathers
now this is something i've took up
myself before with derbyshire county
council the environment agency
and various other organizations seven
trent water to who is responsible for
this within our deeds it states that we
have to keep our bits of uh river clean
now as i say this is this is going to
exacerbate the flooding issue we've seen
last november if you look
again at off the
off the road bridge
there's a pipe runs across and the water
top to that pipe last november when we
had the bad storms the name storms
so as i say
nobody seems to be taking responsibility
in this flooding issue is really really
serious and a threat
and it doesn't seem to be
anybody's responsibility to to keep this
watercourse clear and assist with the
flow
and we know currently this field acts as
a sponge and soaks up a lot of the
rainwater
uh obviously when that's removed and
it's made into hard standing tarmac
concrete and the the top water then is
going to be directly drained into the uh
into the press brook and just make the
situation worse and worse
and he's also remaining
right this is also the coupe lane
development which is then going to also
be put into this press brook
which again just adds more water flow
to this
narrow
watercourse which hasn't been cleaned
out for at least 30 years after the last
flooding in 1982 on these properties
when they're under four foot of water so
i'm just wondering
where we're going to go with that has
anybody even considered that
because it it it really really needs
looking at it
thank you mr barr thank you thank you
are there any questions
no
thank you mr barr we move on to the next
speaker richard eden
thank you chair for this chance to speak
uh right basically i live at six
windermere road um and i'm in flood zone
three
um my property is the lowest property on
windermere road and we constantly have
flooding from our combined sewers which
is sewers and surface water
seven trent are aware of this and said
it's just down to being hydraulic which
is obviously from
uh
heavy rainfall so every year we have
this problem now the brook flooded in
1980 and it flooded all the gardens and
it was four foot in this house
uh now
phillips like to show you the pictures
of the field but it's if they've not
showed you the north west corner which
is actually lower than the rest of the
field that is actually our floodplain
when the brook breaks its banks it
actually flows into there and it's our
safety net their plan is to raise that
land to make their new development safe
from flooding by doing this all right
and they're also on about draining their
surface water into the brook they've
took our safe net away which will create
the water to flow over the banks and
come down the gardens and i will get
flooded you uh also you've got to think
about
there's a majority of old people that
live on this
road who can't speak up for this and i'm
speaking on their behalf as well we have
got uh mr clark who is bedridden and he
is uh
in bed downstairs permanently now if
this was to get flooded his life could
be at risk from this
uh
we've had no help in the past from
northeast derbyshire for flooding and
it's i think we need to look at that
before anything is looked at about
giving somebody planning permission to
exaggerate the the problem because their
surface water they're saying they're
going to drain it off at
the rate of the field but they've
already
chopped the trees down which take
considerable amount of the water and
they've not done the assessment before
they've taken the trees down
so
not going about it in the right ways i
can also
tell you as well i know this isn't
probably relevant but professors
say they own the land as well i have got
to deed
they've only owned it registered it
since 2018 i have got a deed and
conveyance which states the land isn't
theirs i'm not willing to give it now
but i will give it if anybody wants it
uh the true owners of the site
so that proves that they have a job
they have registered that under their
own name
er fraudulently and i can prove this by
deeds and a conveyance
thank you
thank you mr eden are there any
questions for mr eden
no thank you we'll move on to the next
speaker mr mark allen
we were expecting uh mr allen chair but
uh he hasn't actually arrived we're not
sure whether he's given apologies or not
so on that basis um if he arrives then
while this is still being considered
perhaps he could be
given access then but otherwise it's the
next speaker would be dad and abbott
who's the agent for the scheme
thank you
um
mr abbott
hello hi you've got three minutes
thank you for the opportunity to address
the committee i am darren abbott of the
dlp planning limited representing the
applicant ward or homes who are
delighted to have the opportunity to
progress the application site
as detailed in the office of
presentation this is a contained parcel
of land neighboring existing development
in the settlement of clay cross this is
a highly sustainable location of one of
the district's main towns where the
majority of development growth will be
directed the site is allocated for
residential development in the advanced
emerging local plan under policy lc-1
contributing to the district's housing
supply
to meet identified requirements the
settlement boundaries also to be altered
and effectively absorb this site
the proposals offer well-related
high-quality sustainable development
accessible to local services and
facilities delivering a choice and mix
of homes to a range of two three and
four bed properties with 20 affordable
housing provision the proposals also
include six bungalows which not only
meets the general housing need
but offers a provision for people with
disabilities and or those wishing to
downsize thus potentially freeing up
larger housing stock as is advocated in
the national planning guidance the
council's housing officer identifies a
shortage of bungalows in clay cross and
notably a substantial need for
affordable housing
we have worked closely with offices and
key statutory council teams throughout
the application process to ensure
compliance with planning policies and
this has resulted in no status
objections against the scheme
this includes county highways the local
lead flood authority the environment
agency and derbyshire wildlife trust
the environment agency detailed that the
site is not at a heightened risk of
flooding and is consistent with a
sequential approach to development
prescribed in national policy a
site-specific flood risk assessment as
also supports the submission concluding
that the residential proposals are
suitable
for risk will not increase on the site
or elsewhere a view that is shared by
the local lead flood authority
robust ecological assessments have also
been undertaken and highlight the site's
limited ecological value and poor
species diversity
whilst removal of some of the lower
quality trees will occur the proposals
incorporate a comprehensive landscaping
scheme with native species supplemental
planning of fruit trees and wildflowers
for seasonal interest as well as
enhancement of the historical orchard
vegetation along the brook is also to be
retained and sensitively managed
ensuring that its functionality and
repairing habitat is to be maintained a
net gain in biodiversity will be
provided which includes habitat creation
and
enhancement both on and off site with
associated 30-year management
to ensure that the required
infrastructure is in place to support
the development on delivery the
applicant is committed to providing the
full suite of planning obligations
requested
this includes contributions towards
enhanced education provision at tutton
hall school an enhancement of
recreational play part facilities at
clay lane in kenning park
in conclusion being minded that this is
an allocation in the emerging local
plant in a highly sustainable location
with no objections from statutory
consorties and provision of robust
evidence clearly supporting the
proposals would welcome you that's three
minutes chair back in your office
recommendation thank you
thank you mr abbott are there any
questions for mr abbott
councillor foster councillor armitage
councillor house
[Music]
yeah uh thank you chair um
i've heard quite a lot about uh flooding
concerns from previous objectors and uh
other members at
this committee uh about flooding in
different areas uh to do with the press
brook and uh the the the high levels
during periods of heavy rain which it
says uh in flooding
um
you mentioned uh earlier uh mr abbott
that uh about the uh
the flood authority the local flood
authority and uh the other studies that
have been done could you put my mind at
risk there is no concerns those studies
and uh the flood authority but could you
put my mind at rest by just explaining
and a little bit more about that about
what was brought up because we have
heard a lot about uh flooding concerns
and we we only went over it very quickly
there that no concerns have been raised
so could you just
tell me a little further thank you
certainly so
as a starter for ten the um the site is
detailed by the environment agency to be
flood zone one now that is the lowest
risk of flooding so if it's not at a
heightened risk i flood zone two or
three or a functional flood plain then
everywhere else by default is flood zone
one
now the the sites um or to the west of
the site the properties on windermere
roads they are in flood zone 3 and
that's largely as a result that they are
at a lower ground level than the
application site itself and that and
that's possibly results in the
application side being flood zone 1
because of its elevated land levels
already
now the application is supported by
a flood risk assessment and a drainage
strategy
um alongside it and what that does
national planning policy requires the
sites that are greater than a hectare
that a flood risk assessment site
specific one
actually builds upon the information
provided by the environment agency
and and what that um looks at is is
there going to be a risk of flooding on
site and is there going to be a risk of
any development exacerbating flooding
issues elsewhere and that's been um
prepared by a a national um consultancy
in that regard
now um their conclusions is that that
that that it won't increase flooding on
site and there won't be increased
flooding elsewhere coupled with the
drainage strategy that's been um
identified for this particular site so
that accords with the with the planning
policy in that regard
now the drainage strategy is intended
that um
runoff rates or or or the drainage that
will outfall into the into the press
book is no greater than greenfield rates
so
in essence you won't you shouldn't be
able to see a um
a change from what already occurs and
the system has been designed with the
relevant calculations to do that now
these reports have been reviewed and
assessed by the um by the environment
agency by the local lead flood authority
and their conclusions are that
that it is acceptable and the scheme put
forward accords with policy and doesn't
increase the risk of flooding um both in
the site and elsewhere equally
thank you councillor armitage
thank you chair it's really the uh
the flood uh aspect that
uh councilor
uh
uh foster has
mentioned it's uh
you say that you're going to all the
surface water will go into that brook
am i right the the surface water that
will be be captured as part of the
drainage system system yes that will be
tanked and then the flow will be
attenuated out of the site into press
brooke
now um the the the issues as i
understand that have been raised with
flood risk on-site at the moment are the
fact that there's actually a collapsed
sewer a seven trent sewer that um that
runs through the site and if you've got
a copy of the um
the site plan to hand you'll see that it
runs from the western boundary and then
kind of navigates its way through along
the road network as is proposed up to
the northern boundary
and that's the sewer that's collapsed at
the moment now that is due to be
repaired in january as part of the
proposals so the the flood risk
issues
that have been identified
some of which are caused by that will be
uh will be remedied in
in that regard
then equally there's also permeable
paving as well that is proposed that
will allow um
rainwater where it falls to absorb into
the ground and an equally a
comprehensive landscaping scheme with
the coupled with the gardens the
orchards the hedgerows and the trees
that are proposed for the site that will
absorb rainwater where it falls
you've also mentioned about cleaning up
press brook
will you actually be lowering the base
of it
and
we're not really talking about
sewage on this one uh yes
there is a a collapsed sewer and
presumably you'll be uh connecting into
that will that sewer be big enough to
take these uh 30 odd houses yes yes
we've got confirmation and that that is
acceptable from from seven trend water
and this will be done before the hou
before the houses are even built it's
yes it's programmed in for january yes
right
okay
it's just the the fact that
you've got all these uh drives tarmac
and all the rest of it sure and yes
you've got tanking all right and this
sort of thing but when it rains and it
rains particularly heavily
that uh tank will be overflowed and
it'll go straight in it'll also uh
carry with it uh toxic things from these
uh
these the roadways because tarmac is uh
pretty toxic and if you're going to the
water course you've got a problem there
and well an ecological problem yeah
taking this into consideration yeah
absolutely the drainage the drainage um
system that's being designed is there to
account for this and extreme storm
events and it also has um filters and
interceptors that will prevent any such
um contamination of the watercourse
clearly that is that is paramount um and
equally the um the drainage um in terms
of surface water will be wholly
contained within the site and there's
also a again in the committee report
you'll see a condition relating to
pre-construction drainage as well to
make sure that that when the site is
developed during those periods that
equally there'll be a suitable drainage
system in at that time
it's been brought about who actually
owns this site
the ownership um has been raised during
the the application and the correct
notices have been served on the land
owners
ownership is a is a private civil matter
and not one that is material to
consideration of a planning application
but we have um our legal advisers have
responded and there's no concern over
the ownership of this site contrary to
those raised by
neighbouring occupiers
thank you thank you that chair
thank you councillor else
right good afternoon mr abbott um a
couple of things for me
um previous you mentioned about the
flood risk assessment could you tell me
please if that flood risk assessment was
done as a desktop exercise or was it
that you know some engineer went out and
looked at it
yes it would have been it would have
been um initially as a desktop appraisal
as
any of these reports are but then it
would have been followed up by a
site-specific um
a visit and with with further works
thereafter
right and if um we requested to have a
look at that
would we be able to see that yeah it's
it's all online it's in the public
domain obviously it's part of the
planning application submission um
particular so it'd be on the council's
website and that was submitted as part
of the
original uh package
earlier this year
okay
the last one from me uh previous
mr richard eden you mentioned about the
north west corner and being in flood
zone three
uh
it is sorry is that a question is it
fluid zone three or is it is it it's no
no he's mr obviously mr eden said in the
northwest corner that is in flood zone
three
okay that that's contrary to the the
details that the environment agencies
provide
right which identifies for zone one or
by default the lowest risk of flooding
right i'm not too far from this area and
i've i've lived all my life
and for me i'm thinking this could be an
officer's a question for the officer but
i'm not i'm going to ask you could you
tell us
why is the site been cleared already
before permission has been granted
so there has been some some clearance on
site um to allow some further site
investigation works to take place
initially um
noting that those were low-quality um
uh low-level shrub or trees that have
been removed to date but none of those
have got tree preservation as would be
right for a site that doesn't contain
those at present but the purpose of that
was to to to undertake some some site
investigation works
um
uh on the site essentially
right okay i mean i i agree with the
gentleman um one mr eden actually
with no in that plot and i'm sure
councillor armitage will back me up on
this because i'm sure he knows clay lane
very well and so does councillor read it
it has always been a problem down there
of flooding even when i was a small
child
every winter
it would flood
so i'm hoping
that you will consider this
this committee will consider this
lightly
i me personally i don't think it's going
to be good but that's not my decision in
the end
and thank you for darren for answering
me those questions no problem
thanks excuse me chair um can i just
interrupt for a moment um some of the uh
speakers have been using the chat
function effectively to uh comment on
sort of points which they've heard and
take further part into the discussion
now it was made clear at the start of um
the way in which the process works is
that um speakers will have their three
minutes and then we'll have the
opportunity to answer any questions from
members i think that has to apply to the
chat function as well so i'd be grateful
if those still in the room only use the
chat function effectively for the
modalities of actually taking part in
the meeting so in other words you know
if they make sure that they've actually
got the access details and things like
that rather than to actually provide a
commentary on the work of the committee
thank you chair
thank you
are there any further questions
counselor shipment
thank you uh chair um and thanks mr for
your presentation
um what i was going to ask is do you do
you accept that perhaps the collection
of the drainage is not where the
problems are given the fact that it
flooded in 1987. that sounds to me
like it's historic
problem and not something that would be
caused
recent more recently by a collapsed
strain in his sister
and do you also accept that
it's it's always going to be a given
that you if you're building on higher
ground
you're gonna cause problems even if it's
slightly increasing cause it
increases the problem on lower down
properties that are on the same floor
plane
because it sounds to me like like you
you you
right trying to skip over this flooding
problem by perhaps blaming the clutch
sewage
that's breaking it when really it's put
this up more to it than
that being the issue if it's been
happening for 30 odd years now
um this is clearly a historic problem is
what i'm getting huh
okay um
so so first and foremost i don't think
we're you know certainly not intending
to blame this collapsed
drain for or sewer um for for any
flooding issues that that may
have occurred on site but that could
have been the cause of of recent events
but i think the fact remains that this
has been thoroughly assessed um by
drainage experts both in terms of
preparing the flood risk assessment the
science-specific flood risk assessment
the drainage strategy and then also the
the governing body
for flood risk in the district the local
lead flood authority the county council
in that regard
so whilst
you know i i'm not in a position to
dispute that there's been a flood event
historically in the 1980s but what i
would say is that you know we don't know
the cause for that even if that if that
were to occur um but what i would say is
that
if there were technical evidence that
were put forward to counter the the
science-specific um flood risk
assessment that the that even our uh
engineers could review or the uh the
county council as the responsible
authority that are raising has been
clear no objection to this then then
they would have regard to that but that
has not been submitted you've got the
environmental agency that are saying
this is this is the lowest risk of flood
lowest flood risk sites
you've got a flood risk assessment that
corroborates that a drainage strategy
that will ensure that all the surface
water contained
is contained within the site and that
any uh and the um the discharge of that
will be
no greater than the greenfield rates
that currently occur into the press
brook so
on in that regard um
ultimately the statutory consultants are
raising no objection for those very
reasons the environment agency the um
the local lead flood authority and also
seven trent water so i i you know
i can't account for what's happened in
the past because simply there's been no
evidence put forward in that respect
the other question i had was in terms of
the biodiversity and the wildlife
announcement you mentioned that there
were perhaps there were going to be
something on site from the documents
i've read that all the stuff seems to be
offside i just wondered what it is you
had planned for the site uh to enhance
that area obviously once houses go on
certainly
so
this is a obviously this is a an
allocation in the emerging local plan
and
it's a relatively modest size site just
one and a half hectares and this will be
an issue that will
crop up more and more moving forward um
there's a there's a requirement to have
um biodiversity net game and that's set
out in national planning policy and it
will be
you know reinforced legally once the
environment bill is is mandated um
likely next year now
where you have a greenfield site with
development inevitably there will be a
biodiversity loss and that's the ecology
report that has assessed the site um
notes this is of of a low quality
now the the the scheme is supported by a
comprehensive landscaping scheme which
is to be cond which is uh to be dealt
with by condition but indicatively we
have submitted a master plan in that
regard and that's been prepared by
specific landscape architects and that
will include native planting it will
include
enhancements and reinstatements of the
orchard it will include supplementing
and renewing the hedgerows and it will
include things like wildflower uh um and
seasonal bulbs and those will be on site
then coupled with that because there is
the requirement for additional
biodiversity gain
there are um broad principles that we've
agreed in consultation with the the
wildlife trust and the council's parks
team for three other sites within within
the locality and one is directly
opposite are the um the play park at
clay lane
also at charlie park to the east and at
um
pavilion which is to the north of the um
north of the settlement
and again that that's conditioned but we
have provided broad principle in that
regard which which are available to view
and that would result in a net gain in
biodiversity
thank you councillor cooper did i miss
you did you want to speak
no okay counselor armitage
yeah i thought i'd just uh come back
again uh chair it's to do uh you
mentioned about this orchard uh and all
this uh biodiversity who's going to look
after this orchard because
i'm uh
i know there's an orchard uh behind the
fire
station in clay cross and all that
happens there is that uh the trees have
uh
a massive amount of apples and they just
drop on the floor and rot
seems to bother so who's going to look
after this this this this will be
secured by a management company um and
that'll be secured by a legal agreement
so that'll be the the long-term
management of the of the public areas on
site which will include the orated and
indeed the um the wooded uh margins to
the to the periphery of the site as well
and will it also uh to do with the
management of press brook
yes it's the applicant's responsibility
as landowners to maintain that brook yes
within their ownership
right
are there any further questions
thank you mr abbott
adrian i believe you wanted to come in
and say a few words
it's very briefly at this point if if i
may share there's been some uh
discussion during these speakers
comments to members about the air vent
that's on site i just want to make it
clear chair that the air vent itself
isn't a listed structure but the
southern portal to the clay cross tunnel
which is
some distance to the south of the site
that is a listed structure but just to
avoid any confusion with that chair
and also there was some discussion about
land ownership
during the speaker's comments i know mr
abbott commented on that just to
reiterate that share that all the
suggestions made regarding land
ownership have been investigated as far
as we can by officers and the
appropriate assurances have been given
to us chair the
relevant
notices and notifications have been
undertaken so from that point of view we
are satisfied that issues have been
addressed jen as mr abbott suggested
that is the matter that
members need to take consideration of
this afternoon i'm happy to answer any
of the questions as appropriate chair
when and if members have them
thank you
alan i've got one question for you
before we move on and i'll come back to
you councillor rouse um i've just looked
at my
notes late amendment notes on page 16
it's got a request to have a letter read
out
is this acceptable or is it just gone
out with the notes
i'm not sure what that's from chair it
could well be that's us it's from a
previous thing certainly there is a
letter at this stage to be read out okay
thank you thank you to miss it
counselor else
thank you chair it was just um a little
bit
um that i was looking at and i needed to
obviously mr abbott to address it
um if possible chair
uh mr abbott are you still look there
hello yes yes still here
okay
yeah that's okay it's just just a quick
one um it's on page 23 of 4.46
about the coal authority the committee
report yes
um
and it states in there the coal
authority has commented that it concurs
with the conclusion and recommendation
of phase one desktop study report and
coal mining risk assessment dated march
2020 based on the professional pigeon of
the bsp consulting that there is
currently a risk to the proposed
development from a former coal mining
activity
in in order to confirm the exact ground
conditions present beneath and within
this site to inform remedial
mitigationary measures required to
ensure that the development is safe
stable
um
intrusive investigation should be
undertaken prior to the development
and that has come from the coal
authority
yeah so i believe i believe that's in
connection with the
um the phase one death study to conduct
concerning ground conditions and
contamination and equally a coal mining
risk assessment and what that requires
is that the
typically then the phase two
um is is intrusive works within the
ground to understand essentially what um
what remedial and or mitigatory
requirements um there are in order to
deliver the development but in principle
what the what the coal authority is
saying and indeed the um the environment
environmental health officer
and the environment agency in their
capacity concerning contamination is
that there's no barriers to development
in that regard from from the information
they have in concern in the phase one
site investigation which is obviously
not to be confused with the flood risk
assessment or the um the drainage
strategy
completely separate reports
thank you
are there any further questions
counselor shipment
sorry just one was i've just been
reading further on you know hearing
what's been said you know the um the
event
that's for the train i
have been any studies
that i would have thought if people are
living
next door to an event
is some issue some health issues that
could possibly be
is that has that been thought through
are we is because i've not seen anything
when i've read through it
yeah sure
again we'd be guided by the council's
environmental health officer in that
regard and and usually if there's a
concern concerning air quality and the
like there would be
requests for an air quality assessment
which which there hasn't been in this
instance so so the environmental health
team haven't haven't requested such
such details to be put forward in that
regard but in terms of the layout there
is a an offset around the vent um
well where the vents located relative to
the properties to be uh to be
constructed
exactly
or is that because they've explicitly
said one was not needed
that they they haven't raised any
comments in that regards but they if if
even in in terms of if there were to be
say a noise or vibration um concern that
they have um from their monitoring and
records then that would be raised but
yes they've not explicitly referenced
air quality but it hasn't been raised by
the uh
council's environmental health
team as part of their kind of statutory
obligations
any further questions
thank you mr abbott thank you
[Music]
before we move on to
questions for the planning offices i'd
just like the opportunity
to say that the proceedings are focused
on getting clarity about points that you
are not sure of once we have done this
we can then have further discussion
about the application based on what
you've read and heard
for that reason members i would be
grateful if you do not move any motions
at this stage let's wait until we've had
a chance to make our assessments
the same rules apply
are there any questions for the planning
officers
councillor elliot council armitage
thank you chair
earlier we we heard one of the speakers
make mention of the width of the roads
and whether or not the access from uh
the dustbin lorries and so on
wouldn't be a problem
um
i think in the
can't get same can the ambulance can
adrian or uh phil just gives a bit of a
run down on that one
sorry i missed some of the uh
the question chair through the the break
up but essentially the um the hardware
authority haven't raised an objection
and there are conditions with respect to
um
to the visibility displays so um
we're satisfied in terms of the highway
safety implications of the development
and phil also the not only did they
mention about the the width of the
lorries and coming out with egress
access and
entrance sexy to the side
he mentioned about the
the roads play from clay from clay lane
into the side there's some and if i
recall something along the 24 meter line
is there an issue with that as well
um
i can't even retake what the highways
have said that they haven't raised an
objection subject to to conditions so um
as far as we're aware there isn't any
issue with um the development not being
served by a safe and adequate access
i'm just a little worried that if it is
just a desktop survey it needs probably
a little more in-depth
on-site survey just just to make sure
that what we're
what we're looking at with this
application is correct
it it is conditioned that they provide
those visibility displays so it so if in
the event they can't provide those
buildable displays then
they can't um implement the development
so there is that get that caveat
um
yes i appreciate the frustration that
due to covered highways aren't aren't
business in sight but um
like i say from our point of view with
them not having raised an objection
subject to conditions uh we're confident
that
the visibility space can be achieved
to chair as well on the
drawings that have been submitted the
visibility displays have come to clean
lane are demonstrated on their chair
which would give us
the confidence to recommend approval on
that issue to members
thanks adrian
thank you councillor armitage
thank you chair uh it was to do with the
uh hedge on the roadside that uh it's
proposed to take out
uh can you tell me why it's been taken
out and uh
the off-road parking provision at that
point uh what uh
what provision has to be is there any uh
off-road parking uh to the uh
the houses on that side
i'll just start on that uh chair and
then phil might might have something to
add but the
i i believe that council alma tg is
referring to the hedge
along the road frontage and some of that
obviously need to be taken out to afford
access into the site that's inevitable
in terms of the site only site access
being provided that could only be
provided to clay lane so some of that
hedgerow will need to be taken out to
afford that in terms of the the
affordable housing
as was discussed i think earlier on
there is
the affordable housing at the south
western corner of the site southwestern
portion of the site
and the addictive landscaping scene does
show some roadside road frontage
hedgerow being replanted along there but
of course to accommodate the housing
then the roadside hedge even in that
area would need to be taken out to the
first instance and
phil may be able to
assist on this bet that i chair but the
the site itself does provide sufficient
on-site car parking in accordance with
your normal standards to afford car
parking for all the new houses that are
proposed
if i could just come back to your agent
before phil comes in
this comments would it be possible that
if we were going to go forward with this
plan to approve it
that we could sort the
flood
problems out uh once and for all
and that uh the press brook could be
cleaned out before they even start work
i think that that in my mind is
something that's got to be done
uh and this mending of the
sewer so was usually break
because of subsidence
now it's been mentioned about the coal
authority and their
the things that which they said well
with modern sorts of techniques and what
have you in building you can put down a
raft which will alleviate any problems
but uh even if you put the sewer pipes
around pea gravel and things like that
it uh
it you can get problems with sewers
breaking i mean
if we're gonna do this it's got to be
done right before they start and i i i
you know i can't emphasize it more
before not when the halfway on with it
right
thank you councillor shipman and then
councillor foster
i'll just come back to me in a second
sorry
don't you just address those points that
counselor armitage has raised
sorry
yeah phil was meant to be coming back
about the uh
the hedge and road
it was about the car parking i believe
um
um yeah i mean you can see from from the
layout that um that there is a mix of
car parking solutions but but they've
all got on on plot parking um the
majority have got in
two spaces and there are garages as well
so um we're we're satisfied that it
complies with successful places in terms
of the um
in terms of the car parking arrangements
uh also in terms of there being a mix of
car parking yeah frontage and down the
side and garages
just on the
the flooding issues that um council
advantages raise the enchant if i if i
may
mr abbott i think explained that
in some great detail to members and it's
difficult to add to that
but just to emphasize that the issues
that are ongoing at the moment are
ongoing issues and the reasons for that
i think have been discussed in some
detail
and the
scheme that is proposed chair will leave
the
necessary buffers between the
development and the brook
to allow future maintenance as
appropriate through the application site
if that is what is necessary chair and
in terms of the
future
foul land surface water runoff again as
mr abbott explained that would all be
dealt with on site
and in terms of the surface water that
would be tanked initially and then left
into the brook at an appropriate rate
such that the site itself
shouldn't exceed its current greenfield
runoff in any case so there shouldn't be
any additional
flooding impact from this site than as
existing and that's clear chair the
technical consultaes on this have been
very clear and raised no objections and
i've not done anything this afternoon
that would suggest to me that there is
evidence
to suggest that those conclusions are
wrong in this case
these are all very theoretical adrian
and i've seen all this before
and
he is mentioned about a management
company well these companies come and go
and what happens if the management
company goes bust i mean what
backup is there uh you know it's all
very very theoretical and if we as soon
as you get a big downpour
that poor chap in the uh
level three is going to get flooded out
and
he should be protected before any of
this starts and this was my thing about
let's have the actual level of press
brook dropped we've got these problems
in in and around us over
and i've always i know where they all
are and i make sure that they're all all
the ditches and drains
are kept clear and you know i think it's
well local councillors need to be aware
of where the pinch points are and make
sure that they are kept clear
and you know that's just my point it's
all very theoretical until it rains
thank you councillor shipman
thanks chair and i just wanted you to
clear something up for me adrian in the
um report it says the neddc engineers
have commented uh the management of the
surface water from the development a
lack of consideration has been given to
incorporation of subs features
additional details will be required
before the method of surface water
disposal can be
considered can you just explain what
that means if it doesn't mean that
what's been proposed
has been um
as a lack of consideration
i i can come in there if you want uh
chair and the
comments from our street scenes were the
comments when the application was
initially submitted the um the level of
detail application has moved on quite
considerably since then and they were
reconciled on the information but we
haven't had any further comments on them
so those comments were taken at a point
of time
well isn't that quite misleading in the
report because it
why are we not getting
the up-to-date information
to me before it comes before committee
given that we know flooding is a massive
issue here on this one
that we've not got the up-to-date
assessment from any ddc engineers before
it's even come before us because it
seems to me like we're being asked to
make decisions blindfolded whilst trying
to rely on private consul consultants on
flooding issues uh i respectfully screw
that because we've um consulted the
derbyshire flood team which are the lead
local flood authority so in effect the
the engineers and the flood authority
are commenting on on the same this is
the same things
so it's not a private individual relying
on relying on the derby county council
as the statutory council team
so what we're saying is the nadc
engineers have submitted
opposing comments or differing comments
from the leading flood authorities that
are commenting on the same issue
now what we're saying is we haven't got
up-to-date comments from any ddc but we
have got up-to-date comments from the
derbyshire flood team
we have briefings just uh sorry phil
it's fine i just come in as far i'm just
going to to say on that issue chair that
we seek the advice of various bodies and
as phil cartwrightly says the
lead flood authority are the primary
flood agency as their name suggests and
that's the advice that we would normally
rely on clearly if we get advice from
our own engineers we can take that into
account as well however chairs as phil's
also said works gone on on this issue of
flooding over the time of the
application
and
the most up-to-date information has been
assessed by the lead flood authority
on that basis
and i'd urge members to
consider very carefully what the
technical expertise has outlined in this
case and
indeed what's been submitted by the
applicant's own
flood
advisors and their own service water
advisors and to iterate chair i
appreciate and understand members been
asked to consider this matter but
there's an existing situation
in respect of flooding in and around the
site
and that won't change
if the site is developed or not but what
as is always the case chair is that we
are asked to ensure that
new development does make an existing
does not make an existing situation
worse
and the information that we have before
us as officers and which were reported
to members satisfies us that that is the
case in this instance and that the site
could be satisfactorily developed for
the number of houses proposed without
adding to the flooding problems that may
exist at the moment in and around the
site chair
and without any technical evidence to
override that and again i've not turned
anything this afternoon that is
technical evidence to override that
information without that
other evidence or other information
share i'd ask members to very seriously
consider the matter and the evidence
that you do have before you in making
your decision this afternoon
thank you
guys have one more question change all
right very quick
it was it was on the fact that the
unfortunate earlier that the latest
application is the 34 ohms i believe in
the the new local plan which
incorporates hospital on says 25
have you gone back to the developer and
and
said well look this is the local plan in
the immersion this is a plan in the
local
immersion of
why you're not going for 25 because
that's what we've we've agreed as a
council
it's suitable at that point and then you
could actually move it around and start
moving the houses around the site to
make this flooding issue less bright and
what's been the response from the
developer on that is that something that
they'd consider
yeah
if i may just before phil comes in on
the
negotiation that he'll be able to
advise on
and as council shipman
points out that the site is an
allocation in your publication draft
local plan which we as officers
in our report members are suggesting
that significant weight should be
attached to which is which is a
high level of weight in terms of the
scaling and the wording in the
publication draft local plan is to
deliver approximately 25 dwellings it
doesn't set out
25 dwellings per se and therefore it
doesn't prevent members in making your
decision this afternoon
to permit a number
greater than or in other circumstances
perhaps less than but it doesn't say
that the site should be developed for 25
houses
full stop it says approximately 25
houses and as i say chef phil may be
able to
discuss any negotiations he's had with
the developers over numbers but hope
that helps with the local planning
position chair
uh yes please sorry mark here eventually
yeah and yes there have been discussions
with with the agent with regard to the
scheme and and on the issue of the
numbers and and the allocation
but as adrian says there is no upper
number it is an estimated um amount and
in terms of the garden sizes they all
comply with successful places so it's
not um over development as such um and
also there's been no objections from the
wildlife trust on the ecology issues or
the the flood team in terms of the
flooding issues
so um
the um
the scheme in front of you is what the
what the applicants put forward we
didn't feel that we're able to um to
recommend refusal of it on the basis of
the local allocation
[Music]
councillor foster
uh thank you chair
uh
yeah uh perhaps what i'm looking for
here is some clarity from mr slater mr
kirkham on uh
on the on the flood issue
and it's uh that's that's my main
concern about this application what
concerns me is i've had so much already
here from uh local residents and from
local councillors about all the flooding
problems and i've heard an awful lot
from the professional side and from the
lead local flood authority so we've
heard a lot about the flooding and the
historical flooding from objectors and
these local people that are against this
speaking against this
but against that we've got a flood risk
assessment and a drainage strategy that
raises no issues
so so what i'm looking for is some
clarity on this uh in addition we've got
the environment agency and lead local
flood authority which raised no issues
that's on that and then when we look at
the combined sewer uh which is in the
documentation we're told it'll struggle
but at the same time seven trent have
already reported that the flow will
easily accommodate 38 dwellings and uh
the flow from the 38 dwellings and it's
relatively low and it can be
accommodated
that's seven trent they've confirmed
that the existing sewer can service the
new houses
and we've also heard that part of the
site from raider
here
part of the site is in flood zone three
and yet the environment agency are
confirming that it's all in zone one
so what i'm looking at is all this
information i've heard from residents uh
which if we're not careful that could be
hearsay yeah it could be now we take
people on face value and we do when we
hear people speak here we do do that but
at the same time we've got professional
reports
we've got the environment agent said
lead local flood authority seven trent
uh county
and all saying something different
so i i want to be careful here where i
put my uh
you know what
you know what judgement to make and what
way to put on what reports so i'm
looking for some clarity in the uh in
that apart from what people have said
here when it comes to flooding
are there any do we have any
professional reports or any any sort of
report at all
that's uh by an engineer that says there
is going to be flooding here and that's
a question to our officers anything that
says this flooding is going to happen
apart from
you know uh what could be hearsay
i don't know if nikki can can hear this
but on the
excuse me on the flood zone issue if we
could just have the presentation of the
plan that phil went through earlier on
chair does
show clearly where the flood zones are
that may be the easiest way of
addressing that issue checks it's it's
up quite a few nicky if you can go back
almost to the start please
just up a little bit further
and that's that's the one there where
you cursor it that's the one yes
so that's where the
um
flood zones are chair
and
to my reading of that it shows quite
clearly to me that
this site doesn't fall within a flood
zone two or a flood zone three
so therefore the comments that mr abbott
made earlier on about the flood zones
is correct from the data the information
that we have from the
um environment environment agency and
the others who provide this information
thanks nikki that's really helpful thank
you
just in terms of the the other issues
council foster is
correct chair that we as a determining
body need to look at the evidence that
you have on this technical matter and
you shouldn't rely on
unevidenced background or or stories
that can't be substantiated or other
comments that have been made to you the
evidence that we have is from
the professional bodies that
the applicant has asked to consider the
matter and they've submitted their
evidence to the council in terms of the
flood risk assessment that they've done
and the scheme that they've
put forward to address the issue of
on-site surface water chair and that's
been then
professionally assessed by the lead
local throttle flood authority
and the other bodies as well seven trent
yorkshire water etc they've all looked
at that and then they've come to their
conclusion on that and their own
understanding and information and
concluded that there is
no reason to
object to this application on the
technical issue of flooding chair and
also you've heard a lot this afternoon
in respect of the
foul situation the seven trent situation
with regards to the
sewerage situation and how that capacity
would be
put in place to allow for the proper
drainage of the sites the dwellings
proposed
that is as far as i'm aware unless
i'm misunderstanding the situation that
is the professional advice that we have
and that's all we have
the other information that you've heard
this afternoon is from those who live
close to the site and as officers we're
not saying that there isn't an issue for
those other houses
that for the other side of the press
book what we're saying to you as
officers chair is that the evidence we
have we put forward
shows to us that the expertise
identifies that this site itself
should not add to that surface water or
foul
water disposal situation at the site can
be adequately drained in respect to that
chair and i again i reiterate i've not
heard any substantive evidence this
afternoon that would lead me to a
different conclusion
hoping that's clear enough for
counselors that's good enough thank you
thank you mr kirk
any further questions
councillor armitage then we really must
move on
thank you for your forbearance chair uh
yeah it's
it's this uh drainage situation that
we've got
yes you i'm speaking as a professional
here i've been trained and i've done
various drainage jobs
on and around the farm
and it can be overcome
but you have to go from basic principles
to start with and the first thing is you
got to clean the dike the press broke
out
that's to be cleaned out first and then
you put a complete drainage system into
that uh
into the brook and you have to make sure
it will take it not flood the poor chap
out too so he's in uh
number what was it flood range three
uh
and that's got to be taken into
consideration so that brook
is the top priority to be done and this
should be done before any work is
carried out and if we go back to the new
local plan
this was put forward by the previous
administration
and there was no
objection to this site by any member on
that thing it went out to consultation
and there had been no objection to the
site whatsoever
so
it had been a local plan a neighborhood
plan in place then you could have talked
about it better and had a stronger case
the trouble is at the moment we've got
this uh local plan
which is emerging an agent says we
thought great uh weight should be put on
it
but we've had two uh
conflicting reports from two different
inspectors one said no wait should be
put on it and another one said
that we should look at the old one and
the other one said that we should put
great weight on it so adrian how much
weight do we put on this local plan
considering there's no neighborhood plan
which we have in other areas
just on the first point again chair
it's difficult to to say anything new
about the issue of flooding than i've
already said but just to reiterate what
i discussed with council foster a few
minutes ago chair the evidence that
i have seen leads me to conclude that in
terms of this site
it will not add to a flooding problem
chair and in
addressing the issues that have been
raised you have to be proportionate
in terms of the development that is
proposed and you shouldn't be seeking to
impose unnecessary or disproportionate
requirements on the developer of this
side chair and with the
buffer zone that's been left and as
officers we believe that appropriate
maintenance of the brook could take
place should you grant consent for the
housing development this afternoon chair
just in terms of the the local plan
again as i've said a number of times to
members chair it is for you as a
planning committee to determine what
weight you believe is appropriate to
publication draft local planning or
report as officers
we've taken a view that because of the
level that the new local plan has now
achieved it
consultation on the main modifications
as officers we've taken a view that that
should then attract significant weight
which
is
going to the top end of the the weight
that we believe you should attach which
is not full weight but it's achieving
that significant level of weight now and
as has been discussed the site is a
draft allocation in that plan and
therefore in our recommendation chair
we've placed significant weight on that
allocation in bringing forward our
recommendation
to you in terms of the the various
issues that council army says about
inspectors decisions
you may get a chance to discuss the most
recent later on this afternoon chair of
time allows us and yes we do have some
difference of difference of opinion
between inspectors over a number of
appeals over the past
few
appeals that we've received on these
larger housing sites however that the
principal still remains chair that you
must start with your development plan
and decisions must follow on from that
and in your development plan as it
stands extent development plan the site
is in the countryside
however as we've discussed previously
there is
a level of uncertainty about how much
weight you can rely on purely and simply
that the site lies outside settlement
limits
and therefore share in our
recommendation to members
in placing that significant weight on
the emerging plan that does add
significant weight as as it's suggested
in what i've just said
to that so that's letters on on
bringing together all those issues
that's led us to recommend approve of
the scheme to member's chair placing
significant weight on your publication
draft local plan
thank you
are there any further questions other
than flooding
that the
members want to address
no
okay thank you very much officers um we
can move on to the next part
um again we this is where we can open
the floor for debate
and i would please ask that you refrain
from moving any motions until everyone
has concluded their discussions
uh with that
colleagues the floor is open
excuse me chair would it be helpful if
at this point
i was to um go through the room
thank you
thank you chair uh please bear in mind
members that a motion must be moved and
seconded before a vote is taken if an
amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then that motion will be voted
on for or that amendment will be voted
on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations fails or in other words
it is not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations
are automatically approved
rather
you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion in
favor of the recommendations or another
course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote thank you
chair
thank you i'm going to open the floor
for debate councillor armitage
right unmuted uh well i think most
people have heard my arguments uh
for and against this uh
thing
this uh application the problem is that
uh if it were to go to appeal
uh i think the
uh was the weight of argument uh by the
experts
would uh
make the uh inspector
find in favor of the applicant
and
no doubt would land us with a large bill
and that's my honest opinion uh i
on uh you know i mean we've got to put
various conditions on before they start
work especially with the drainage
that's my point of view
anyone else
counselor foster
yeah um
i'm afraid i'm much the same as
counselor armitage in the i can see all
the feeling against
this and i can see all the people that
have objected but i've not heard
anything yet that shows that this
committee can
actually uh
properly uh
reject this uh
this application of playing permission
at all uh flooding is the main issue and
i've had all my questions answered when
it come to my my concerns about planning
i have
um
[Music]
and
my concern is for
it's not just for this actual
application it's it's for
you know it's it's for the council at
the end of the day this will go to
appeal and
do you know uh
i don't see it there's others there's
any way we can uh we can say there will
be flooding there based on all those all
those reports
so i'm pretty much the same that's my
view
thank you
any other few council shipments
yeah
i have to i have to disagree that
there's plenty of things that this can
be objected on not least because
the allocation of housing is higher than
what's in the emerging local plan
and the fact that the existing local
plan doesn't have discipline whatsoever
so under
lc1 at least in the new one you could
object
i'm struggling with the sustainable
aspect given the hard part the roads are
around there
and the lack of infrastructure
investment in especially the flooding
issue which was saying there's not one
but ultimately
we can request that something's done to
life if that's the condition we want to
put on it
um
but
i i think the main issues for me is hey
there's an event on site and i thought
if
there's a motion forward to approve this
one of the conditions needs to be
evolution assessment surely
um and then there's i think
more work needs to be done around the
flooding because whilst consultants are
really good at bringing us reports with
what the developer wants i i we've seen
firsthand on developments throughout
this district where
derbyshire county council will say
nothing
that's not necessarily that they agree
with the proposal
that's that they have no comments on the
proposal if they don't think about an
aspect that we thought about in
committee that will come up in the
appeal that we could perfectly argue
and i think that the
given the housing allocation is 36
percent more than what we've got
allocated in the emerging local plan
that alone could reject this proposal
and that's how i'm going to be going to
i just think there's too many houses for
that small plot of land
fairly the discussions have already been
added in the local plan process
on why it hasn't been higher than 25 i
mean to say
that the number 34 is even remotely
approximate for the number of 25 when
it's such a small development
is that's just not correct clearly 36
increase percent increase in houses is a
huge amount more on a bot that we've
already allocated so
you know if no one else has got anything
else to say
uh i'm ready to propose a motion if
that's okay jay i'll leave that with you
to let me know when
[Music]
anybody else any comments to make
with council shipment
i think looking at the local plan as is
it's not even meant to be in there and i
think the
we're already over subscribed for
housing in clay cross this is a
land that's the only bit of greenery
that's going to be left around that area
and i think it should be left intact i
think the flooding will come to light
very quickly we're in the winter months
the rain's going to start coming down
heavier and i think you'll soon find out
if we put extra houses on there that the
ones at the lower end of the uh the
development will be the ones will be
flooding and going into the ones that
sit down below them so i'm i'm with
council russ shipman
any further comment
counselor foster
yeah all those last comments all sound
fine but they're not real reasons for
rejecting this at all none of those
okay um where are we now
having heard everything that's uh
accounts for hermitage oh
yes
adrian sorry
william carry on
okay thank you uh can i move to go with
officer's recommendation can i just uh
ask
adrian kirkham to come in at this point
before we move the motion
there's just one point chair about
housing numbers that
has been raised and as we've discussed
again many times
the level of housing numbers is never an
upper limit and you're always permitted
to
grant more than
a level of housing that's
proposed chair so the fact that there
are housing
coming forward in and around clay
crossing elsewhere wouldn't preclude you
per se from granting consent for an
additional number of houses sharing i
hear what council shipment says but if
otherwise the site can appropriately
accommodate the numbers proposed chair
that wouldn't in itself in your office's
view be a reason to refuse the
application
thank you
thank you councillor foster
yeah i'd happy second uh council
armitage's uh
motion uh to go with officers
recommendations um
again we need real reasons to be able to
reject something like this it's not here
say
and it's not because we don't want it
you've got to have real reasons and i'm
terribly um
and that's based on what i've heard from
all sides and especially based on what
i've heard from officers
thank you
i just want to clarify something with
our clerk alan
i believe councillor shipman didn't put
in a motion to start with before anybody
else uh there hasn't actually been a
motion which is approved and seconded
other than as i understand it they're
the one from councillor armored teaching
council of foster
okay can i just make a point of order
the only reason we got to that situation
was because i respected the request from
you not to put an emotion
yeah exactly and therefore
i didn't get anyone to second it because
of that reason you can't then have
someone propose a second emotion
straight after giving that i've just
given you that
yeah that's why i wanted clarification
counselor shipment
council foster
yeah i understand council shipman's
point but uh fact of the matter is there
is still only one motion which is being
proposed and seconded it might have been
somebody's intention to hold back and
all the rest of it and it might be
something somebody else's intention now
to second that motion but as it stands
there is still only one motion which has
been proposed and seconded and it
couldn't be any clearer
there's one motion currently
thank you councillor armitage
i'd just like to make the point that
this new local plan
uh i was on the steering committee for
this and when it was
then this site was brought up there were
no objectives to it and it's all right
coming now an object into it but you
know it's too far on
thank you right i'm going back to the
clerk now alan
yes chair i mean i think as things stand
it's obviously a matter of the chair's
discretion ultimately but you do have a
motion before you which is to um go for
office or router to approve officer
recommendations all i can simply say
that is the motion which is before you
okay thank you right can i ask
councillor armitage to put his motion
through properly this uh you know go
through it so everyone is clear
and then i'll ask councillor foster if
he still wishes to second it
yester it was to approve the uh it was
to prove the uh
the uh
planning application and to go with the
officer's recommendation on it thank you
councillor foster
i'm happy to second that and i think
it's uh it's the right decision it's the
only one we can make uh it goes with
office's recommendations and it follows
all professional reports and advice
there is nothing else thank you thank
you
can i now have a show of hands just
before you do that i just want to be
clever
does the planning manager uh have any
comments before we move to the vote
no chance as far as i'm aware the uh the
motion is as per officer recommendation
chain
uh comfortable um okay taking the vote
uh thank you
thank you can i now have a show of hands
so
are we going to actually do this by roll
call
uh we can do yep are you okay with that
nikki yes of course chair so as is
normal practice now for virtual planning
meetings we will uh take the vote by
roll call
counselor elliot
four
councillor foster
four
councillor huckabee
i'm just going to give you a prompt
unmute counselor huckabee
[Music]
thank you castle huckabee
council pots
or
casa powell
castle ridgeway
against
castle rouse
against
councillor rough
for
and councillor shipman
chair i make that seven votes for
four against with one abstention which
means the uh the motion is carried to
grant
along with officer recommendations
subject to the section 106
thank you very much thank you members
and thank you any speakers that are
remaining
up to three o'clock
so do we want to take a break now or
move on to the second one a break now
okay i say 10 minutes
okay so we will be back here at five
past three past right
our
next planning application which is
reference number
two zero forward slash zero zero four
zero nine four slash rm
this is
reserved matters application for 180
dwellings including details of layout
appearance and landscaping
percent to 17 forward
zero zero two six eight forward slash
and before i go on to
ask for the
presentation from the offices
i'd just like to remind you all
that the access point and the number of
dwellings has already been determined
so this isn't the ideal place or should
not be the place for any debate about
such matters they have already been
determined at appeal by the inspectorate
thank you
so the
i have here
the report is going to be given by
adrian kirkham
that's correct chair yes whenever you're
ready
off you go thank you very much thank you
before we get on to the presentation of
a couple of late updates to bring to
members and also a brief introduction so
if members can bear with me please but
firstly chair just to draw members
attention to the late updates report
that was circulated yesterday in
addition chair
we've received a letter confirming that
yorkshire water has no objections to the
scheme
we've also received a further letter of
representation from the applicant's
agent mr hill who will address you
shortly i believe he sets out a few
points as follows chair
the sweat path analysis has been
completed in conjunction with council
officers to ensure that refuse vehicles
can access all areas of the site
the road spurs referred to in
correspondence will either not be
offered for adoption or have been
included to allow for proper refuse
collection purposes
the design amendments made address the
comments of the police
the urban design comments are noted but
further amendments would reduce amenity
areas to houses and connectivity
and share the landscape areas will be
managed by an appointed management
company with native seas trees being
predominant in the public areas
including at the site entrance with all
the more appropriate species planted
where they're closer to built
development
and on the merits of the scheme chair
the applicant's agent states that the
road network has been designed to the
satisfaction of the refuse service and
the highway authority
and as you've just mentioned the outline
approval addressed issues in respect to
the character of the development its
impact on the area and specifically its
scale and the issue of access
during subsequent discussions share with
officers further amendments have been
made to increase the density of the
development at its center decreasing it
towards the perimeter of the site
allowing for soft edge enabling it to
integrate into the area
it is similar in density to the area of
housing to the south retains area of
open space along the southern and
western edges in particular
additionally chair the outline contender
poses conditions that will require other
features including wheel washing to
enable on-site construction to be
undertaken sympathetically
overall chair the applicant's agent
considers the scheme of a high quality
sympathetic an asset to the area it
includes 40 percent much needed
affordable housing public open space
play area and public art
and he doesn't consider there any
technical reasons to resist the
development and so no reasons why
members should not be able to support
each air
just in terms of the the application
itself before i come on to the
presentation
chair
seeking consent for the three reserve
matters of layout appearance and
landscaping further to the granting of
outline planning consent as you've
already mentioned in november 2018
at such general its rate the points
you've made the considerations in this
case are limited to those issues only
and the other minor issues that are
referred to in the officer report and
for clarity the issue of the principle
of development of the site and
matters relating to its access and scale
are not open for consideration by the
planning committee this afternoon chair
the application seeking consent for 180
dwellings will be two-story in scale
saved for those along the northern side
boundary which will be one and a half
stories high as required by the outlying
consent granted and 40 of the units will
be affordable with one quarter of those
as socially rented housing
it's identifies addition to the east of
wingworth and it borders countryside it
comprises chairs we'll see in the
photograph shortly two fields for the
central hedgerow tree spine
it's bounded to a large extent by trees
and hedgerows and slopes gradually north
to south access to it will be taken off
spindle drive to the south
members will note there aren't any
technical objections to the scheme
officers have entered into discussions
with the applicant over the details of
it and the suggestions put forward by
officers and how the scheme could be
improved in design terms have generally
been accepted and well received by the
applicant the amendments made
it's resulted chair in a scheme that
officers believe offers a high standard
of design with a clear sight gateway
feature buildings at key points
generally good boundary treatments and
out refacing design
the celebration of key features such as
trees
the general retention of trees and
hedgerows
officers also considered charity creates
a legible design with good access within
and around the site
the only area that remained unresolved
was to the northern boundary where due
to site levels and the need to form the
block structure of the development the
units will not face outwards
however even here the applicants have
agreed to implement a green fence along
the most prominent part of the site such
that it will soften this boundary
the associated issues of affordable
housing climate change and landscape
ecological management are all considered
satisfactory to chair
in conclusion officers consider the
scheme a good design solution for the
site and recommend the applications
approved in accordance with the
recommendation on page 85 of your report
chair if i can just ask nikki to bring
up the presentation i'll just go through
the
various slides we've got a number of
photographs chair that hopefully
illustrates some of the points that i've
made but this is
the application site
and this is the
drawing that is contained in your papers
check comes out better on this slide
than in your paper so i apologize for
the poor quality of that but it does
show access to the south taken from the
existing spindle drive and then
accessing onto dielens road
as i've mentioned chair that point of
access has been agreed and approved by
the inspector on appeal back in 2018 it
isn't a matter for consideration by you
this afternoon
the the scheme is set out there share
the amended scheme and as i've mentioned
it provides an officer opinion a good
design solution for the site
the areas to the west and the south in
particular offer
good
open areas of space with retention of
trees and hedgerows there are gateway
buildings a block structure
and as you can see the central spine of
the hedgerow within the site is being
retained and will form i mean officer
opinion attractive walkway through the
development
there are footways around and within the
site
except to the northern boundary a little
bit of the northeastern area of the site
chair but otherwise good access within
and around the site and this is a
coloured up drawing showing roughly
where the existing trees they're in the
the darker colours and the lighter trees
and the lighter colours will be formed
the only area where there is some
retaining
issues to be considered and discussed is
in the south west southeastern corner
share where the attenuation basin is and
we just need to bring to get bring
together the ecological and landscaping
imperatives that we've set out with the
need to provide that appropriate surface
water
attenuation basin and that is therefore
conditioned as per one of the
recommended conditions chair
thanks nikki
the
line a and bb
and as you can see at the top line that
exemplifies the point i made about the
entrance into the site with the rendered
finish of those buildings which turned
the corner into the site and officers
believed correct
thanks nikki
the top two lines here show the one half
story units on the northern boundary of
the site again using different materials
to create those focal points and areas
of interest
also share within the site is a good use
of boundary features and particularly
estate railings to create some nodal
points and again the areas of interest
and legibility throughout the site
thanks nikki
the next few slides chair i'll ask nikki
to just move through these relatively
quickly but they show some of the house
types
and their various two-story units but
with additional features on the gable
ends as appropriate chair and then the
use of render as i've discussed and
these ones show the one and a half
storey units
rocked by the northern side boundary
and finally chair the the photographs
this is the
taken from the close to the entrance
onto spindle drive with deal and road so
this first portion of the
roadway here would be used to access the
site
you can just make out a car in the
center right of the photograph roughly
opposite there would be where the access
point would divert off the existing
spindle drive and then go through the
the hedgerow that you can see there over
a bridge over the brook and into the
site proper and the next slide nikki
will show a closer up
point of that particular position so the
access will go roughly in this location
forming an entrance point through that
hedge row
and then we're going to the far south
eastern corner of the site now these are
some pictures along
the tricky brook
and show how the brook is well vegetated
creating that um
very attractive boundary to the site
so the tree line there is along the
brook and all that vegetation except
where the access would be formed would
be retained in the form of backdrop for
the site and these photographs go back
up towards the
site access showing how
that feature will be
integrated into the site save the access
going through it thanks nikki
and that's getting back to that point
looking in the other direction the house
is on the far left of those on dealings
road
and we i'm going up hockey lane here and
the feature trees on the right will be
retained and this seeks to show chair
that hockley lane is generally um it is
a it is a public right-of-way
it's not to be used as part of the
development of the site
um and it will be retained in roughly
this form with a hedgerow and the
hedgerow trees being retained
thanks nikki
and now onto the the site proper chair
the large tree that's to the left of the
photograph forms the tree in the north
western boundary of the site that's in
the hedgerow with hockley lane
the houses beyond the hedge row to the
right those currently being constructed
off hockley lane and then the houses the
bungalows to the far left of the
photograph are older units that form
part of the village of wingwood
previously and then hockey lane in
between there but the field in the
immediate forefront of the photograph
doesn't form part of the site the site
boundary is formed by that tree i've
mentioned
following down hockey lane and then
coming across the field to the left
thanks nikki
this is looking from roughly that same
point but in this photograph you've got
hockey lane and the hedgerow and the
trees on the far right
and you've got you can just make out in
the murky distance those are
houses that form the developed off
spindle drive so you can see the
hedgerow and the trees that run along
tricky brook and then the hedgerow on
the left is the hedgerow that will form
the central spine of the site with that
being retained and forming um in office
opinion an attractive walkway through
the development so the site boundaries
roughly
in the hedge that sorry in the fence
that runs from the left hand side of the
photograph across to the middle right of
the photograph
thanks nikki
this is taken from a similar vantage
point but that hedge now is the central
point of the site so we've moved
slightly to the east looking down again
towards the south
thanks nikki
and similarly the edge row there with
the houses off spindle drive to the far
right of the photograph
thank you
this is now looking along the northern
boundary there is some hedgerow some
tree features along there
it is rather a disparate hedge and trees
and belt that forms that boundary but
that will be formed of those houses that
are mentioned the one half story units
the tree that you can see roughly in the
mid right of the photograph we'll have
some closer views of that in a second
but that is the tree that would be
retained in an area of public open space
and as i've mentioned celebrated at the
end of one of those runs of housing at
the end of the the street to provide a
focal point and the applicants have
worked with us to ensure that is an
integral part of the scheme
thanks nikki
and we're now on the eastern boundary
and that's the tree that will be
retained within that area of space
you can see the remainder of the site to
the right that's the other
field beyond the the central spine hedge
row and just in the far distance you can
see the other houses that occupy the
land off spindle drive
thanks nikki
and then this is looking from that point
back across the site you see the
hedgerow i've talked to quite a bit
about in the the middle of that
photograph and the houses to the far
left there existing unit spindle drive
and others thank you
this is looking back along the the
northern boundary that would foot that
hedge line tree line would form the
northern boundary of the site and as you
can see the levels rise relatively
steeply at that point compared with the
rest of the site
and they would be this one half story
units along that boundary in accordance
with the requirements of the outline
consent
thanks nikki
this is back towards the the central
spine hedgerow that's on the right hand
side you can see the houses off spindle
drive in the middle distance with the
tricky brook line of trees and hedges
just in front of there thank you
and a similar um sharp chair back down
across the field towards the south of
the site
thank you
that's looking uh back across the the
northern boundary of the site back from
where
you've come from the uh the tree that
i'm keep on mentioning is that one on
the far right
thank you
and similar views now chair the the
hedgerow on the left-hand side the field
in the the foreground and then hockey
lane the boundary hockey lane on the far
right
let's get back to where we started the
tree on the left hand side is that one
that's on the
north western bound through the site
looking back down that central spine
hedge row
there's just one or two more i think
nikki
this is the final slide this is back on
hockey lane hockey line goes off to the
right and this is just an indication of
the development taking place on the
other side of hotly lane from the site
so the application site to the right
hand side of hockey lane
development is under construction on the
left hand side there and it's showing
the setback from the site boundary which
will be mirrored on the development site
itself the only difference being that on
the application site there will only be
a private drive between hockey lane and
the houses whereas on the development
you can see there that is a road to an
adoptable standard so it's more
engineered and a deeper setback but the
new development that we're considering
this afternoon would have a setback not
as deep as that but will be similar that
to the other side of hockey lane
that's it nicki thank you
thank you are there any points of
clarification at this point before we
move on to the speakers
no
thank you we'll move on to the first
speaker which is councillor barry lewis
is councillor lewis here
ah yes
i'm here thank you very much indeed and
thank you chairman and members of the
planning committee for giving me
a few minutes to uh to talk about this
particular application we have all heard
that it's already been through an appeal
um which was uh which was lost sadly and
uh we are now looking at a 180 house
development here so there's not much we
can do about the main access but perhaps
there are things that we can do to
address some some some other issues
i've often spoke of the the scale and
number of developments around lingard
being unsustainable and impactful on the
on the village and it is now looking
increasingly over developed so that is a
concern i think for for all of us um
this is also a very significant um large
green space within the village but to
get to matters that really sort of
matter and will hopefully help with the
uh um the overall process that we're
dealing with here today um
and that is to tackle some of the things
about the internal layouts and uh and
ensure that
they that they meet and
need and fit for purpose uh for the
village uh basically and um i understand
that rip and home have a good reputation
uh generally for meeting their
obligations around affordable uh housing
and have done so with regard to this
particular site so i do at least welcome
that i would however welcome the the
opportunity to have conversations with
ripon homes about improving things about
the internal layout making sure it meets
its biodiversity obligations with regard
to this site um welcome welcome to here
that uh many of those hedgerows will be
retained but there are a couple of
perhaps crucial aspects which we may
need to consider um nowadays um
applications of this nature and scale
should really be considering
looking at not just bricks and mortar
which this one seems to be
but look at development that is a lower
carbon um in the future and this is a
future development and perhaps we should
be pressing that and looking at things
like
micro generation as well to reduce the
electricity burden on both the national
grid but also to provide a greener
alternative to lighting and heating
within those homes um opportunities as
well for ensuring that we have
electric vehicle charging points as
standard for most of these sorts of uh
um houses should be discussed and
broadband is a massively important issue
and we have we know we've had problems
in parts of winger within the past we
should consider broadband as being
something that uh as equally as
important as having a water supply to
one's home or electricity to supply and
therefore consider um that uh opening a
conversation i would be in fact
welcoming of a conversation with ripon
homes to ensure that we can then uh sort
of get the best deal that we can out of
this particular seconds remaining thank
you in regards to
this particular site
so that we can maximize the opportunity
both for winger with
currently but also for future residents
that will be utilizing this site thank
you chairman
thank you are there any questions
no thank you councillor our next speaker
is tony carter
mr carter yes i'm first yes i'm here now
hello
a long time waiting
right thank you very much for the
opportunity to speak about this i
represent uh well i speak from a person
who's got a
boundary with the site but i know that
what i'm saying is represented by a lot
of other people who would prefer not to
speak personally
the the issues about uh
entry to the site
i know have been
discussed and we're not supposed to
discuss those at all because it's all
been decided but since
the
inquiry two years ago uh the amount of
traffickers improved increasing greatly
and no access no allowance was made for
the extra houses that uh stancliff are
just uh building opposite and may i say
at this point that uh the picture
of access from hockley lane
onto the standcliff that's to say hopley
garden site that is only being used
for the purposes of the builders
it will not be used by the people there
they will have to have access uh through
nether close
and they will experience the same
difficulties as you will as the people
in this will experience in getting onto
uh dylan's road via spindle drive unless
spindle drive is widened
and the bridge is widened
there will be a great deal of trouble
anyway move on
the intrusion into the countryside and
loss of wildlife
and so on will alter the character of
the neighborhood it was claimed at the
inquiry that there would be a gap of
about 20 25 meters between the houses at
the top of the site and the boundary the
development now this does not appear to
have been realized
and that will make an increased and
significant loss of wildlife habitat
a lot has been said about the north
south retained
spine hedgerow but that won't help
because that will lead to nowhere
the
ground across the top of the site would
have allowed the free movement of
animals this will not
because we all know that the local
primary schools are full the school
proposed on the avenue site will still
be full when that large estate is
completed almost all these children will
have to be taken to school by car
somewhere with consequent environmental
impact and pollution
doctor surgeries are always already very
busy
those of us who suffered from the
building works when the first phase was
made will know that
i suppose it's inevitable that it was
extremely noisy but this is a very much
bigger production and
in the summer it will be necessary to
wear ear protection when you're in a
garden anywhere near
seconds remaining
uh we were assured that yorkshire water
would solve the problem of sewage
disposal which had been causing a lot of
trouble even before this development
can they please inform us what actual
steps have been taken to deal with this
issue with the addition now of 30-yard
houses
from uh in hockey gardens and there's
180. this is something that i haven't
heard anything about except that they've
done some surveys
we've already got three minutes
thank you
thank you mr carter are there any
questions for mr carter
no thank you very much thank you
we can move on to the agent paul hill
mr hill
thank you
my name is paul hill from rps and we're
speaking on behalf of ripon homes um
members will have read the very clear
officer report and just for clarity
the reserve matters application follows
very very closely the details approved
at the outline stage
it has to do so as condition three of
the outline consent requires this
submission to accord with the
illustrative let approved at that stage
so issues such as the detail of the new
axis on the spindle drive have already
been approved along with the overall
scale and density of development on the
site
and further matters detailed matters
already addressed within the officer
report
at paragraph 2.2
chair i've addressed this committee on
many occasions on many sites over many
years and i can genuinely state that on
all the sites i've worked on
more attention has been paid to the
detail of this application jointly with
your offices
and consultees than any other site i've
worked on and rightly so particularly
given the location and sensitive
activities of the site
it is to be observed though that there
are no objections from the technical
council teas including
the district council's street scene and
parks teams the county's urban design
and landscaper architect and the highway
officers
the member scheme as advised by officers
has introduced many improvements
reinforcing the block structure already
approved by the illustrative layout at
the outline stage being an out refacing
scheme retaining an attractive setback
and frontage to hockey lane along with
the direct pedestrian access to it it
also provides links between the open
spaces the central spine along the line
of existing hedgerow and a defined
entrance into this development with
feature buildings and locations agreed
to the outline stage
very considerable collective efforts has
paid off and this has resulted in a
scheme acknowledged by your officers as
representing good urban design with a
variety and distinctive features
throughout it
so chair in summary there is no basis
for seeking to resist this application
the decision on the outline consent
acknowledged the site is not prominent
in the landscape and would not be
prominent or out of character
the development is well related to the
settlement edge resulting in a well
thought out unattractive scheme
the provision of 40 affordable housing
represents a level of provision
which in recent times
is
fairly unique i would say chair and
recognize seconds remain ripping homes
has fully delivered on that level of
provision within phase one
overall chair i trust the very clear
recommendations of your offices will
therefore be endorsed and the proposals
approved
thank you for your time
thank you are there any questions for mr
hill
councillor armitage
uh thank you chair uh it's been brought
to
our uh
notice about the wildlife corridors
because we don't seem to have any and
also
uh when this went to appeal
or when it came to committee last time
to be for approval
or photographs which uh people put in
not just flooded areas but there was a
great deal of sewage coming up i mean
can we have your assurance that these
problems have been overcome
thank you chair through yourself um in
relation to ecology matters uh yes there
is a full landscape ecological
mitigation management that accompanies
this submission
so it does provide a lot of details and
a very detailed land landscaping plan
that we've worked hard on the officers
that included many many revisions to it
and includes an additional 156 trees on
the site
many of which are native trees in
particular those public open space areas
and in relation to the the sewage issue
chair
this matter was
addressed at the outline stage and i
won't go through the inspector's report
but there's a huge amount of detail that
was looked at and proof of evidence by
by experts on this on this very matter
but just for clarity um there is a
public sewer um which runs in effect
along the southern edge side of the site
and that then goes sort of travels
northwards in the joining field and this
development would connect up to that
sewer
and the appropriate um investigations of
that suit have been undertaken and
modeling undertaking that's been
confirmed by
yorkshire water
that that means of mitigation and
outfall is appropriate indeed the
wastewater treatment plant is also
suitable and acceptable to take the
discharge from the site
um so hopefully share that that answers
those queries
yes but uh you know if
it couldn't handle what the what was
already there let alone all these houses
and uh
wildlife corridors i can't see any
really on these plans and
you know it's a development in the open
countryside and i think that we should
have had a few more uh wildlife
corridors allowed and also
uh heating heat pumps solar energy you
know green things
and uh electric charging points and
there's nothing mentioned yet on this
plan
chair i've probably said enough about
the the ecology side of things it is
detailed very deep in the landscape and
ecological management plan
there's also an accompanying
sustainability report that does look at
and address the sustainability
credentials that will be delivered
through the site it talks about airsoft
air source heat pumps it talks about
electric vehicle charging points those
are very detailed matters but it does go
into those and it will fully meet the
requirements of the building regulations
which is the next stage in effect in the
approval process
thank you chair
any further questions
counselor shipment
yeah thank you chair i just wanted to
clarify if you look at the plans with
the obviously the spine of trees down
the middle
i i just can't fathom while the footpath
to the right of that
i don't understand why it's on that side
of the road
uh making it i mean if you're
if you have a disability and you're in
one of those houses you don't actually
have a footpath to your door you
actually have to
walk
you know if you've got a wheelchair or
something you have to actually go down
the road
go up your own drive
and i just wondered why the fluff is not
the other side of the road like any
normal development that we've seen in
front of us as long as you have an
explanation for that
yeah there's a footpath just to be clear
uh sure there's there's a we've retained
the length of that central hedgerow the
only two areas which in effect have been
punched through is to
take the the spiral that goes through
the center of the site that follow the
illustrative layout
the outline stage and indeed the
footpath follows the illustrative layer
that was approved at the outline stage
there's a footpath on that right a
public footpath on that right hand side
that connects all the way from in effect
the north to the south on the right hand
side of the edge and connects to the
leap at the bottom the bottom of the
southern part of the site um so it's
been designed by that for that purpose
we had to provide appropriate
setbacks and appropriate connectivity to
the to the open space on either side
any further questions comments
thank you mr hill
we'll move on are there any comments or
questions to the planning officer
okay um i'll open the floor for
discussion and debate
barry's speaking at the moment and then
i do apologize
um well there was no comments at the
point that i started to speak so i was
just going to move officer's
recommendations
uh it was just the point that uh
when i saw uh
when we first uh looked at this site it
was
a terrible mess as regards the sewage
and it's all right getting
it couldn't handle the sewage that it
has already got and i think
like the foot the site that we've
mentioned before
we have all these uh
things uh put in place oh so cold put in
place
uh and yorkshire water said oh yes we
can handle this but it could handle the
amount of sewage that was going down uh
previously to this i mean it was an
absolute disgrace what was happening
the site is a wet site you know like the
last one
but in spite of all this in spite of all
the
toilet paper and feces running all over
the site
the uh inspector went with it
and uh
you know i couldn't understand why but
there you are
counselor armitage i can update you on
the you walk through your uh yorkshire
water they are actually doing work down
there and they've done quite
comprehensive um surveys
and they are in the process of um
purchasing some land to put in extra
pumping stations etcetera so i don't
have a real concern anymore about this
and i'll bring
adrian curcum in at the moment i'm just
going to on that point chair just
um reiterate what mr hill has said to to
members chair the the issue these issues
were raised with the inspector when
considering the appeal a couple of years
ago
and were resolved certainly to the
inspectors satisfaction then but he did
impose various conditions that aren't
before you this afternoon but which will
need to be
addressed at the appropriate time and mr
hill is aware of that and the office
clients that will then require these
details to be agreed with the council at
that point chair we will of course
consult with the the various bodies
yorkshire water seven trent et cetera et
cetera to ensure that the appropriate um
foul and service water sewerage systems
are put in place that's one of the
reasons why at this point
the attenuation basin is still an
outstanding map because that will need
to be designed both to achieve the
ecological
enhancements that we're looking at and
which members have talked about in which
again the applicants
and uh mr hill have said they're willing
to work with the council to achieve but
also to ensure there's an appropriate
engineering solution so both in terms of
ecology and surface water engineering
there are still matters that we're
working on but we do have an
understanding with mr hill on behalf of
his clients that we will work towards
those solutions and i reiterate with
the comments that mr hill have made we
come across many developers but in this
instance i think the commitment the
ongoing commitment by the applicants to
deliver on that promise to provide 40
affordable housing
is actually one way that the developer
in this instance is showing yes they do
wish to work with the council and they
will wherever possible keep the
commitments they've made in front of the
the inspector back in 2018 with your
officers subsequently chair hopefully
that provides a help and clarity and
reassurance to members on those points
yes uh
thank you adrian uh well uh
without being uh accused of jumping in
too early i'll second that uh motion
that uh council larry has put forward
thank you
you have them before you is to move
officer recommendations
[Music]
are you ready to move to the vote
yes please
okay uh members we will be um voting um
um for against rob stain to go with the
offer of sorry officer recommendations
uh which is to grant permission uh can
you clearly say for against or abstain
announcer armitage
counselor barry i'm not sure your
microphone is working or
casper cooper
or cancer elliot
or
councillor foster
four
councillor huckabee
four
cancer pots
for
cancer powell
oh
cancer reader
or
cancer rouse
or
cancer rough
and counselor shipment
or
chair that is 12 votes for zero against
zero abstentions officer recommendations
are carried
thank you very much
application number three
[Applause]
this is ned 4 2 0 4
7
0 0 7 9 5 4 fl
application to very condition on
planning application 18 forward slash
zero zero one seven seven
forward slash fl
and over to the planning officer to give
his presentation
if i refer members to the late comments
where we could comment
on the
slides please
emily we can't hear you very well
yeah sorry
is that better thank you
thank you chair i refer members to the
late comments where we've received
comments from both an objective and the
agent got the slides please
thank you
this is a retrospective application to
vary condition to the approved plans of
planning application 18 forward zero
zero one seven seven forward slash fl to
allow for the increased footprint alter
height of roof verge detailing amended
doorway positions proposed fenestration
changes to the internal layout next
slide please
the application site is highlighted in
orange and is located approximately 300
meters to the south of the
b5075 and darwin forest country park as
a point of reference
and he started 110 meters
to the north of the neighboring dwelling
charlestown
site is out is located outside of any
design settlement development limit
this slide shows the location plan the
site features a central location
which is open in character and vampire
fields
to the east is an area of woodland which
is managed by the woodland commission
whilst further south there are two
dwellings the applicant's dwelling and
the neighbouring dwelling
thank you
this slide shows the block one of the
buildings subject to the application
detailing the proposed hard landscaping
which will surround the building this
will comprise of a one meter wide
footpath a disabled access ramp and an
area of grass creek to allow for a safe
access to the building thank you
the next slide illustrates the floor
plan the building will be used in
observation shelter and dingy store
store water filtration and a disabled
toilet the elevations plan illustrate
the one meter increase in height which
has created a super roof pitch verge and
fenestration details
this slide shows the approved amendment
elevation plans this shows a lower
building with a more simplistic verge
and fenestration details
thank you
this slide shows the proposed
landscaping plan including further
enhancement landscaping for the planting
of additional trees and shrubs around
the site which over time will provide
screening for the site thank you
the first photo is taken from the east
of the site
showing the side elevation of the
building to the left and background of
the photo is the neighboring property
flash farm which features a similar roof
design and detailing the next one
thank you
this is a third photo taken from the
east showing the front elevation of the
building including the wildlife hatch
opening thank you
this photos taken from the west of the
site showing the fenestration details it
is noted that the area around the
building would be made good and reverted
this is a favorite photo take it from
the west of the site adjacent to the
pond the photo shows a large amount of
planting that has already been
undertaken which over time will mature
and soften the side
thank you
this photo is taken from the side of the
building looking back towards the
african dwelling and the neighbouring
property which are cited approximately
110 meters away
thank you
this is a further photo showing the
existing landscaping which has been
planted around the site in the building
to the centre
thank you
this is a favorite photo taken from the
field to the north looking back towards
the building the pond and the
neighboring properties
thank you
and lastly this photo is taking closer
woodland area to the east of the site
showing the entirety of the site
and that's the end of the presentation
thank you chair
thank you are there any points of
clarification at this point
councillor potts cancer armitage and
bear in mind these are just
clarification
yes thank you chair um
my question emily relates to the the
neighbors um
your report said that there is one
neighbor 110 meters to the north
um i'm sure one of the complainants
stated that they lived 40 meters from
this
building could you just clarify that
please
yes and just just for clarity it may be
my mistake but the neighbor neighboring
property is to the south of the building
to me um
but in terms of the distances um i
believe the 40 meters is to the boundary
but 110 meters this building
council armitage
yeah uh
could you it's outside the settlement
development limit and in in the special
landscape area this isn't it
um that's correct it is outside the
settlement development limit however
it's not within special landscape areas
that was mentioned in the late comments
okay
thank you
move on to the first speaker which is mr
keith moore
are we on we are yeah
you have three minutes mr moore
sorry
three minutes from when you're ready yes
okay uh i am keith moore uh our house is
charlestown directly overlooked looking
my neighbor's development which is
situated within us we were informed it
was a special landscape area
the principle of development here was
established by the granting of the 2017
wildlife scheme which consisted of two
small wildlife bombs
surrounded by a wildflower meadow
it is not just stated by emily
in the report in paragraph 8.1
my neighbor i breached his consent when
he instead constructed a three times
larger than consent to deep water
fishing lake
there is no wildflower meadow
the field grasses is moan short and the
pond is heavily stocked with fish
and because of these factors the site is
no longer considered to be of much
wildlife value
or value to an environmental scheme
this is also the current view of the
derbyshire wildlife trusts ecologies
which i've spoken to on the phone
when these factors include the truth
intrusive car parking around the lake
fishing matches and other at other times
and a domestic style building and it's
likely domestic use is considered as a
whole
it is evident that harm to the special
landscape area and public community now
outweighs any ecological and
environmental benefits which this scheme
had promised to provide
our residential privacy and the mean to
here at charlestown are harmed by the
activities around this building and late
the 2018 planning application was for
boat store and a bird hide
the current building has all services
connected
and it is not of a design which is
required for safety purposes
the unauthorized domestic features
including glazed trench doors and
windows the unauthorized increase in the
builds building's height and footprint
the unauthorized burst increase in the
size of the pond for use of the fishing
lake the unauthorized dumping of
hundreds of tons of excavated clay waste
material
tree root stumps and other rubbish next
to our boundary
illustrate the disregard the applicant
has for us and for the planning system
the late addition to this application to
provide
for disabled car parking
can you hear me yes no can you hear me
yes
did you hear what i've been saying yes
yes he's telling me it stopped
uh can i continue from where i left off
yeah i'll give you in a few more seconds
yes carry on yeah did you get the 2018
planning application push for boat store
did you get that far yes
okay i'll i'll continue from then for
may
be unauthorized domestic features
including glazed french doors
and windows then authorized increase in
the building's height and footprint
the unauthorized vast increase in the
size of the pond for for use and
efficiently
the unauthorized dumping of hundreds of
tons of excavated clay waste material
tree root stumps
and other rubbish next to our boundary
illustrate the disregard the applicant
has for us on the planning system 30
seconds remain
the late addition to this application to
provide for disabled car parking what
will eventually become a patio area
around the building will surely lead to
further planning used breaches
the original controversial controversial
sighting and now the unauthorized
domestic design features of this new
building do not comply with planning
policies ss1 ss9 pps21 ct1 ct13
gs1 gs5 three minutes chair
yeah i'm just going to learn a couple of
extra
okay
thank you mr moore um
message from adrian kirkham he was
wished to say something adrian just just
very briefly chair just to clarify the
point about the special landscape area
you've you've mentioned in in my report
i do set out at perry up 2.6 it's within
the designated special landscape area my
apologies chair that's my mistake the
site does not lie within the special
landscape area but it is within an area
of countryside so i apologize for um
that era chair
thank you
are there any questions for mr moore
no thank you mr moore
[Music]
thank you chair
okay move are there any questions now
for the planning officer
counselor armitage
uh could you uh
just confirmed as it's
no longer in special landscape area uh
it but it is development in the
countryside
uh as such isn't it
as in uh and it's outside you know it's
contrary to ss9 what are we writing this
chair just just on that um the site has
never formed part of the the special
landscape area as i say
my apologies for my mistake on that um
the 2005
local plan and clearly sets out where
the the sla is now as you know in your
publication draft local plan
the social landscape areas are not being
introduced into that but and my
apologies again share the site does lie
within the countryside yes as as council
armitage says
you will need to consider whether you
believe this development is sympathetic
to and acceptable within the country's
countryside your policies don't preclude
development within such areas but you
need to make sure that their character
appearance is is appropriate and you
need to balance that and as officers we
don't believe the proposed country to
that policy and in that we take into
account
what is already permitted as emily
outlined to you in the presentation so
there is a building approved on the site
and we've also taken to account share
the
nature of the building where it's
located the level of landscaping that
will over time grow up and ameliorate
any impact so we've taken all those
things into consideration sharing our
recommendation to
yourselves as the planning committee so
as officers we don't believe it would be
contrary to your policies but of course
you as the decision maker need to take
that view and come to a balanced
judgement on it
but the footprint's far bigger than uh
originally uh
proposed isn't it
again chairs emily's outlined to you
that the building is
slightly larger and slightly taller than
has been approved yes but uh that
doesn't necessarily chair make it
unacceptable you need to have that make
that judgment as to whether you believe
it's in accordance with your policies
and acceptable
in this countryside location i've set
out the issues that we've taken into
account as officers in our assessment of
the mata chair
thank you thank you
councillor barry
thank you chair um i think for me
looking at this this is nothing like the
plans that were originally passed um
regardless of
whether it's well built or not um the
original design was far smaller with the
roof height being nowhere near what it
is now
it didn't have a window at the top half
of the
roof
um and it wouldn't have had french patio
doors it had wooden doors for a boat to
be brought in and out of the the
building
i'm a bit concerned adrian that we
we seem to be
um
saying it's all right for you to go off
track and not follow the plans that
you've had past and that we're not going
to object to it because all right it's
not too far away from what it was going
to be well from what i can see of it the
building is nothing like the original
building that was proposed you haven't
got the wild meadow in there that was
proposed you've got a massive fishing
lake instead of two small ponds
so to me this goes right against the
application that was passed
and i don't see how we can possibly
accept what has happened to this
property
it's you know i mean i know we can't
project what might happen in the future
but the way this has been built and
altered
is certainly open up for other
applications in the future
it doesn't represent what we passed um
and i think we've got to go back to what
we passed and i'm sorry i don't agree
with this application i don't agree with
um some of the comments that have been
made in the report
about that um you know the height and
everything is still within
a reasonable um size it's not it's not
what was passed and we shouldn't be able
to carry on letting things like this
happen
thank you
jeff i may just briefly come back
to uh to you on the points accounts that
barry's made and as officers we we
accept absolutely that it's not as
approved as set out in the
presentation that emily gave to you
we've set out there the the plans that
do have permission and can be
constructed and we accept that this
isn't in accordance with those
hence the need for the application
that's the path that we've taken the
fact that the building isn't in
accordance with what's previously been
approved shouldn't be the determining
factor you need to consider whether the
building has constructed or almost
completed whether that is acceptable
and when set against your policies and
all the other matters that you may wish
to take into account and that's the
judgment you need to make
not just that it isn't in accordance
with what was previously approved
are there any
accounts to foster
are we still on have we opened it up to
debate now are we still on asking
questions to offices i'm sorry if i
missed that
questions of officers at this point
thank you
are there any further questions
no
councillor armitage councillor shipman
yeah uh
they i noticed that yes it is
retrospective
and uh the other thing is
the size of ponds uh which were
originally uh
uh suggested or we which we gave
planning permission for
as uh you know it's greatly
it's about three times the size and the
fact that they're heavily stopped as
well
looks to me very much uh i don't know
whether you think our members think but
looks as though it's going to be a
commercial setup for uh
one day fishing permits and things like
that and judging by the number of cars
that have been seen there uh that's
what i think
and the actual building
well you could live in it couldn't you
it's all connected up
okay councillor shipman um if i could
just come in there please
yes certainly carry on emily thank you
chair and just mr cancer armitage um the
the ponds do not form part of this
application we're only assessing you
know the amendments to the building
we're not considering the ponds of this
application
and initially there were two separate
applications
yeah i'm just looking at the reasoning
behind it
thank you councillor shipman
thank you chair um
is this a retrospective
planning application
or have are we asking for amendments to
the original one
and they've just gone off to kill
what's happened with it because i don't
quite understand what's going on here
because i wasn't here for the passing of
the first one
it sounds
have they just done whatever they wanted
to and then now they're coming back for
us to correct that
is it is it possible to share through
you just to ask nick if she can bring
back the the presentation hopefully
that'll help explain to
to members what's happened here and
emily will be able to
um
come in if i get anything wrong but if
you you know just bring the presentation
back up nicola
apologies i've set it up for the next
application if you just give me a moment
audrey do you know which where where
you'd like to see
it's just the plans the uh we've got um
the plans of what was what has been
approved is
it's about five or six slides in to
just a couple further on please
sorry about this just just while the
nikki's doing that to chair yes as
council shipment says the
we have approved
an application for a building on the
site so that has consent
the applicants have then
for whatever reason built something not
in accordance with those drawings
and they're now seeking consent in
retrospect to retain it so it just of
those on the left hand side mickey it's
uh two no one up from where you are now
so just that one there
please
so that's the building that has consent
that's been
consented and as you can see it's got
the the double doors in one side and the
wildlife hatch to the north elevation
and the small window on that west
elevation and the windows to the rear to
the toilet and the store and water
filtration
element of there and then if you can
just go
up
um i think it's that yes
that's what is now the subject of this
application so
as emily outlined it is
slightly larger in terms of its
footprint and taller but it's in our
viewers offices it retains
the features that were originally
in the other building either the two
side doors the the wildlife hatch and
the storm water filtration area disabled
toilet etc
and
you need to consider whether that
building is acceptable or not the other
issues again as emily's mentioned
are other matters that are under
investigation in terms of the altered
pond
configuration size and we're following
that under
up under its own investigation but this
is the building that's before you so in
short um cancer shipment yes it's a
retro retrospective application seeking
to retain what's built
bearing in mind that on the screen now
is the fallback position as approved
thanks nikki
thank you are there any further
questions
counselor reader
yeah it's a comment and counselor and
roth am i allowed to comment now or has
it got to be a question
realistically it should be the next bit
okay
any further questions
thank you
i'll open the floor now for discussion
and debate and i think councillor foster
was first then councillor reader then
councillor shipman
uh yeah thanks for that chair uh
my concern for this is it doesn't seem
to be following what was it was
originally uh given permission for
and much like comments have been made
already to me it looks like this could
almost be a domestic property
and it could be a domestic property in
future that's what it looks like to me
uh
from what councilor bravery said uh
earlier i definitely support her
comments uh condition two was there for
a reason
uh this 1.3 meter taller to me is out of
character with the area and in excess of
size uh required for its use
uh so my own comments are this um
this is contrary to policy be1 of the
adopted local plan
which requires the new development
should respect the character and
appearance of the surrounding area so be
one of the adopted local plan and policy
gs5
which requires that development should
not be detrimental to the character and
appearance of the site and should not
have a detrimental effect on the
amenities of neighboring occupiers and
uses so policy b one of the adopted
local planner and policy gs5 uh if
officers want to comment on that or
other any other councils want to comment
on that but they're my comments and that
it
um
that
it goes against those two policies thank
you
thank you councillor reader
yeah i find myself uh agreeing with
councillor foster and he's literally
taking the words out of my mouth so i
won't labor it and then just exactly the
same feeling really
thank you councillor shipman
yes similar really i i mean this comes
down to the fact is would we approve it
if it came to us now and there was no
previous one that's why it both started
me
and my feeling is you know we wouldn't
with double glazing dolls and
you know it basically being a
a small
bungalow if you like
um
and i don't think we would approve it
because it is in the countryside
and to me it's got to blend in with the
countryside and therefore features and
fittings need to be award and you know
if if it's what they say it's going to
be which is a dingy store
then it should have wooden doors in it
and it should be almost a shed if that's
right that's what it is they wanted for
a viewing shed basically and i think
that it it shouldn't need that level of
you know intricacy if it's just if it is
just a view instead
and i think that on the basis of where
they're at with it i don't think we
would approve this application if it had
come to us for us today anyway
um
so i'm hearing on the side of rejecting
this application and it returning back
to the original one that was approved
and is that a motion council shipment if
everyone's done speaking
then yes
i'll second council of foster's which i
think he was trying to do may just come
in chair just to grab the clarity that
council foster was asking for please at
the appropriate time chair yeah if you'd
like to do that now that's fine adrian
um
as officers with anything to to add
chair cancer shipments correct you need
to consider this on the basis of would
you give permission for what's before
you that's right bearing in mind the
fallback position all the other matters
so that that's exactly consideration you
need to to undergo just in terms of
council foster's points chad
noted that um the motion is set out as
the building
is
in would be in the opinion of the
planning committee out of character with
the area
due to its i think um council foster
mentions that the increased size and
height
and then council foster mentioned a
couple of policies chart i think with
respect he was probably meant to say
policy gs6 rather than policy gs5
um and note that chair
and
policy be1 but i'd also um ask members
chair if you're minded to refuse the
application on that in any reason for
refusal we'd also recommend that you add
in the policies in the publication draft
local plan the corresponding policies in
terms of countryside protection and
protection of your development in terms
of the character and appearance of the
area so there's equivalent policies to
gs6 and b1 in the publication draft
local plan chair
okay thank you if there's no other
council of foster yeah i'd i'd actually
put that uh in the motion gs6 be1 um and
to refuse
okay can we have clarification then on
the motion for the clerk
okay so the way i've caught that then
it's to refuse the application for the
reasons just specified in terms of its
uh failure to meet um
the requirements of polite policy in
particular gs6 and the others which were
mentioned is that the essence of the
members
ap 13 as well alan
ap13 landscape character
in in the emerging local fundraise
just just on that point to chair um
forgot to mention the the asheville
neighborhood plant that
i think council shipman is referring to
in terms of the
relevant policies protecting the
countryside and character of the area my
apologies chair that that would be
appropriate to add those in if members
are minded to refuse the application
but i would ask sheriff
who was a minute to refuse the
application that the final wording is um
agreed with yourself before final
issuing that's okay yourself and council
barry would be normally we'd agree with
that's fine thank you
so to refuse the application for the
grounds that we've now just discussed uh
with the final conditions or the final
sort of uh um sort of a wording of this
uh agreed uh by the planning manager
with um yourself and with the values
chair
i'm happy to propose that yeah
i'll second that okay
so it's moved by councillor foster and
seconded by councillor shipman okay
nikki are you ready for a roll call
yes of course chair so the version is to
refuse the application uh please can you
clearly say four against or abstain
counselor armitage
counsel barry
or
castle cooper
for
councillor elliot
council elliott
sorry for
how's the foster or
tesla huckabee
for
cancer pots
oh
chelsea powell oh
cancer reader
oh
council rouse
or
cancer rough
and cancer shipment
four
that's 12 votes four zero against zero
abstentions and the motion to refuse has
been carried
thank you everybody
and we can move on to the final
application which is nad forward slash
two zero four slash zero zero nine two
one
forward slash flh application
of um to allow garage repositioning it's
amended plans
at kobe lee
i'm going to ask
planning officer to give their
demonstration yeah just before alice
comes in if i can just make one point
about um
a number of the photographs we've been
asked to to put in the presentation to
you they'll come at the end of this
presentation chair they're photographs
that have been
asked to be shown by um various parties
and we've acceded that as they've been
primarily including the late reps report
but they're seeking to
exemplify points made by third parties
that will speak to you chair
they are they are annotated
appropriately but we just need to be
clear that alice will go through those
with you chair
they are not officer photos jim we can't
take any responsibility for the accuracy
of what they're seeking to depict but
i'm sure the various speakers will take
you through that in due course
thank you
over to you alice
thank you
thanks nikki thank you chair
this application is to allow for the
repositioning of a garage approved on
the planning application 19 forward
slash
00255 flh at cloverley chapel hill
ashover
i refer members to the late comments
that we have received um from
uh some of the objectors and they're in
the late comments pack
um
so just go carrying on um cloverley is
located on a corner plot with chapel
hill on two sides
and you can see it highlighted in orange
on this plan
to the southwest of the site is a
private access road which also serves
the properties to the north west
i can have the next side please
the garden of clover lee slopes deeply
away from the house
this proposal is for a detached garage
situated in front of and below the main
house the roof of the garage will serve
as a garden accessed from the double
doors to the front of the property
the land slopes away from cloverley and
away from lee's house the house next
door as a result the garage will be
built into the hill in the northwest
corner in the northwest corner
next slide please
due to the problems with levels the
applicant has found it necessary to move
the location of the garage two meters
further forward than that approved under
the 2019 application
it will also be set down by 40
centimeters from the level of the patio
the garage will be slightly closer to
the bound you would lose out to the west
by approximately 70 centimeters however
it's still 3.5 meters away
a parapet wall of one meter in height
will enclose the garden
you can see the plants here
um the cut out area of this parapet wall
shown on the front elevation drawing
there um shows that a fence will be
installed two meters behind the parapet
wall
and this has been put forward by the
applicant as a way of preventing general
access to the last two metres of the
roof garden which will render the usable
garden space the same as that approved
in 2019
we could go on to next slide please
um
application 1900 255 flh which was
approved in 2019 included alterations to
the main house as well as the
construction of the garage and that
these are the plans for that the
proposed garage is to be built of
natural stone to match existing house
and ash over vernacular can we go to the
next slide please
as you can so these are the plans that
were approved in 2019 and as you can see
the garage design was the same as that
proposing the application you have
before before you today the main
difference is the new proposal is two
meters further forward from the house
than that of the 2019 application the
new proposal is also to be set down
by 40 centimeters it is also
approximately 70 centimeters closer to
the boundary wall with the house to the
west
and if we can go to the next slide
i hope these photos will give you an
idea of the site so this is a view of
cloverly from chapel from the bottom of
chapel hill so you can see the house in
the middle there
you can see the base of the patio just
in front of the french windows
um
the garage will be built forward of this
to the right is derwent cottage and to
the left of global league
is lisa
none of the houses to the east of chapel
hill have windows directly overlooking
the development site
next slide please
this is a view of the proposal from the
private road to the east of chapel hill
you can see the base of the patio so
that's that
bit with the holes in it and and this
this will have a one meter high wall on
top of it
the reef of the garage will be
positioned 40 centimeters below this
space and will come forward by seven
meters
again there'll be the parapet wall on
top of it
and if you can go to the next slide and
then the one after because we've got
them in that's another view from the
same that's it um
this is another view from further up
chapel hill in front of touchstone
um
as you can see uh so you can see that
there's some hedging there um
and the
the roof of the garage will be sort of
in that gap that you can see there
um next slide please
uh oh sorry i've just lost my place
oh yeah and this is the view from in
front of hawthorne cottage so a bit
further up uh chapel hill
and note that there is substantial
hedging and there is potential to
condition the improvement and retention
of this hedge
if we go to the next slide please
this is going back down to the bottom of
the site so this is the view along the
private road which forms access to
cloverly and then goes further on to the
other properties further on the fence to
the right is the garden of cloverley and
the fence to the left is a boundary with
overcroft which is below
and then the next slide please
thank you
the patio has been constructed and the
footings and concrete plan for the
garage have been installed the wall in
the foreground of this photograph is the
rear of the garage and this is 6.5
metres forward of the house the garage
will come forward of this by seven
meters to the timber shuttering that you
can see in the foreground there
a parapet wall will encircle the garden
on the top
note the vegetation on the left between
the patio garden and these owls it is
considered that this helps to reduce the
impact of views from the garden back
towards the windows in the side of lies
owls
next slide please
this photo shows the relationship
between the proposed garage and the
boundary with lee's house there's a 3.5
meter gap between the side elevation of
the garage and the boundary wall
next slide please
um oh
this oh sorry
did we just skip one or have i gone
wrong i'm sorry
never mind uh no go on go to the next
one that's okay sorry um so this is a
view
um into the into the garden of these
house from the um
from the gap uh between the two where
the drive's going to be
if we can go to the next one please
oh yeah thank you and so this is the
view from um
the uh top of the patio into the garden
of lee's house as you can see these
views are of the bottom of the front
garden and the drive a lot of the area
of the garden most closely associated
with the house actually sorry could you
go back to the previous slide i've just
forgot to make a comment yeah and you
see the little hedge in the middle there
behind there the the person who has that
houses does have
um
it seems to have like a table and some
chairs so they probably do sit out there
um
if you can then move on to the slide
after next sorry to jump backwards and
forwards there we go um
this is the view from
uh the garden to the front of these
hours looking back up towards um
cloverly
and the last slide please
and this is another view
taking from close to where they have the
table and chairs um
the garage that's approved under
permission 19225 flh will approximately
be in line with the um there's a rose
bush in this two toiletries and the rose
bush in the middle to be approximately
in line with that um
whereas the garage
proposed under this application is
approximately in line with the small
tree on the right
um in the right hand side
um the the following um
photographs are the ones that have been
submitted i i can either just go to show
we can just go through them or i think
we can are we able to use show them when
the speakers are speaking nikki
um yes i can do that
um
i don't know if that's going to be
easier i think it probably will be
okay thanks alice are there any points
of clarification
not questions or comments just
clarification
counselor armitage and then counselor
parts
yeah uh on the plan that you've got on
page 97
it shows that the actual red line
uh encloses the private road that goes
up so it's
it's totally inaccurate because it looks
as if it's much bigger
uh the actual
site that is actually shown
uh and
you can see that if you look at the
photographs which you provided which
show vans being parked on that actual
uh on that piece and you've also said
about there are no windows overlooking
uh some well there is from the counting
house there are there is a window from a
lounge overlooking uh the site at clover
league and would have been right in
saying that this is a retrospective
planning application as we can see
uh i mean why uh
uh why can't people just stick to the
plans which are passed and you know i
mean are they incapable of
following simple
measurements so if you could just
rectify that please um so the red line
um has to include any lands that's
required for carrying out the
application so of the development so in
this case
the the access so that's why the red
line the access is within the red line
because you have to be able to access
the
garden from the highway
um but it's it's not in the applicant's
uh ownership is it it doesn't have well
if it isn't
we i don't i don't think i think they've
said that it is in their ownership
um
well it's public access through to the
uh
um as far as i'm aware they haven't
um submitted uh they haven't signed
certificate b
so they've said that they own that land
right
um so as far as
i
when i made my visit i couldn't see how
any houses with
side uh windows that looked onto the
applicant's site but i'm um
yeah if i've missed that then i
apologize
yes
and as far as the retrospective
element goes the
applicant has a permission and he has
built
yeah that there has has been uh i mean
no doubt he's going to speak and he will
explain why hasn't been able to build it
at the
in the location that was intended um
so
it is well retrospective
it is in the sense that it that the
footings have been put in but the actual
building has not been constructed yet
well all those blocks are built up
aren't they
yeah that's the front of the patio wall
isn't it yeah
and also the fact that uh
something like uh i i believe six loads
of ready mix were put in for the base of
this
one so in my uh
judgment this has been started so it's
retrospective
they're about able to speak at this
point it's michael whiteman no you you
you're not allowed to speak at the phone
adrian curcum chair just just very
briefly yes just one one query i've got
of councer armitage i think you
mentioned counselor arms there was a
window in at the counting house
yes are you able to to identify that on
the um
the plan in the papers which one that is
please i can't see a counting house on
there
uh it's on chapel hill
as part of it is opposite the entrance
right what's what's shown as cottage at
page 97
yeah there's two there's two things
there are two buildings there
if you see there's a dividing wall and
the counting house is the top side
right okay yeah i know what you mean now
and just on the issue of the the issue
of retrospective or not as alice has
outlined
chair the building that the applicant's
seeking consent for
now that hasn't been completed yet he's
uh he may have put some footings down
and built some block walls but again as
alice has outlined he does have
permission to undertake certain works
there so in this instance i think my
view would be
this is a an application for which he's
seeking consent for rather than an
application that is seeking consent to
retain its totality and i appreciate
there may be some overlapping between
the two but he's certainly not finished
construction of the building as you have
before you're on the plans that you've
just seen
thank you councillor potts
thank you chair but councillor armitage
um
he read my mind that was exactly the
point i was going to make it this to me
does look like a a retrospective um
application um as it clearly has been
started thank you thank you
are there any further questions for the
officer
no
okay
um with that we'll move on to the first
speaker which i believe is councillor
chris miller's bachelor parish council
councilor miller good afternoon
my name is councillor chris miller and i
live in the village of asheville
uh i am thank you for letting me address
you today as a member of asheville
parish council and i'd like to speak to
you regarding the planning application
two zero slash zero zero nine two one
forward slash flh to allow for garage
repositioning amended plans at globally
chapel hill ashover
ashover parish council does not agree
with the recommendation put before you
for the following reasons
we believe that the relocation changes
the character and appearance of the site
and has a significant detrimental effect
on the amenities of the neighbors
including great loss of privacy and
light caused by the proximity and bulk
of the structure in the proposed new
location
this also does not take into account any
noise pollution created by the
activities within the garage or from the
terrace
this is demonstrated by a submitted
photograph using a 4.5 metre high ladder
sat onto the actual building footing
i would also like to bring to your
attention that whilst the parapet is 4.5
meters high at the front
any person using the terrace standing
would have a sight line approximately
6.5 meters
above the ground level
i have submitted and thank you for
showing the photographs that show the
picture as from lisos
the principle of development has been
accepted and is granted in application
one nine forward slash zero zero two two
five four slash flh
however the relocation completely
changes the outlook from the neighboring
properties
this is not in accordance with
neighborhood plan policy ap1 sections a
b d and h and local plant h5
northeast derbyshire local plan gs5
accepts development for the original
grant but does not take into account the
significant impact of the proposed
relocation
it is also reported in clause 7.8.2
of the officers report that users of the
overlooked part of the garden at lee's
house is not that which is closely
associated with the house
whereas in reality this is the main
pattern of the garden for lisos and it
will be totally overlooked
in the last 18 months we've had numerous
complaints received by asheville parish
council in relation to noise
environmental contamination and highways
obstruction
each time requiring attendance by
officers from enforcement and the police
at considerable cost to the ratepayer
our conclusion ashover parish council
opposed the new location of the
development as it is contrary to the
neighborhood development plan where we
were looking to ensure that if any
development was under 18 seconds
remaining thank you then it should match
in with its surroundings should not be
an eyesore and should not cause any of
the neighboring properties problems or
annoyance thank you very much for
listening to me
thank you are there any questions
counselor armitage
yeah uh you uh counselor miller you've
mentioned about uh
uh the nuisance uh of
of this development already uh
could you uh perhaps tell us a bit more
a bit clearly uh what what these
nuisance problems have been
thank you council armitage i'll i will
expand as best as i can and we fully
understand that any development will
cause a nuisance factor however
the nuisance factors that have been
reported to asheville parish council
have been quite considerable in this
event including blocking of roadways
restriction of highways
um environmental issues caused by dust
and noise even through weekends and bank
holidays
uh this is typical of the sort of
situation that we we have heard about
and been reported to us
in your judgment
does the council
look at this as a retrospective uh
development
i have to say council army says that i
am not a planning officer however
having visited the site on several
occasions and viewed the existing works
there is evidence of the
considerable footings that have been
cast further forward from the original
location
caused by
problems that i will not elaborate on
because i do not know the details but
the location is completely different
virtually the whole of the gardens of
cloverly are now taken over by the
footings for the new garage total loss
of the original amenity of the gardens
of cloverley
thank you councillor
thank you
are there any further questions
no thank you councillor miller thank you
very much
move on to the next speaker which is
mike
thomas there chad can you hear me you
have three minutes mr thomas
right thank you i live with my partner
in touchstone which is now bring
property to the applicant now i'll make
a few general comments then table three
specific requests for the planning
committee to consider
i must first of all say that the
overriding theme in all eight letters of
objection relate to concerns about
privacy and it's with this in mind i'm
very surprised that in most of the
pictures taken from neighboring
properties the planning officer didn't
extrapolate the roof line by drawing it
in on the pictures
i know that uh luckily we've seen some
from other objectives also um i'm
puzzled as to why the planning officer
didn't stand on the patio itself and
take pictures looking east i noticed
there was one from west that would have
given a much better perspective as far
as my interest in touchdown are
concerned
i can certainly say this with some
confidence because a few weeks ago the
applicant's contractors were having a
tea break from the patio gazing down my
partner who was in our garden
these emissions are very frustrating
because they would have made the level
of privacy intrusion much clearer to the
councillors who are considering this
application
i believe all stakeholders just want to
get this over with if it is approved
then here are my three requests to the
planning committee
firstly the parapet wall and screen
fencing on the southern elevation of the
of the patio
does not extend to the eastern side
overlooking my property i will look in
my garden now therefore ask that such
screening or parapet wall be included
and set back two meters from the edge to
protect my privacy
second the planning office is summing up
sets out a condition that the hedge on
the eastern boundary with chapel hill
should be replanted where necessary and
kept at a minimum height of one and a
half meters above the wall
it isn't clear what where necessary
means and who makes that judgment figure
eight from the presentation
that clearly shows a complete gap of
around four meters and a further section
of around seven meters of dead or dying
hedge which is as an effective screen is
worthless in other words a run of
approximately 11 meters of mature
hedging needs to be planted and this
will need to be mature um i.e about two
meters tall plus as opposed to plugs of
50 centimeters which would take years to
grow
therefore please could the wording of
this condition be strengthened
accordingly
third to date the only cause i've had
for complaint to the applicant direct
has been the clouds of dust generated by
the cutting of stone and grinding out of
pointing the health hazard of inhaling
such dust billowing onto our property
was a major concern
an imminent phase in the project is of
course the construction of the garage
which will likely mean a significant
amount of stone cutting with consequent
dust and noise i would therefore ask the
committees to require that effective
dust and noise suppressant equipment be
in place for the duration of such work
and as a final point the applicant used
to notify neighbours when deliveries
would block the road
unfortunately this look this courtesy
lap some time ago and would ask that it
be reinstated thank you
thank you
are there any questions for mr thomas
no thank you mr thomas
mrs kirby
hello
hello mrs kirby just take your time
you've got three minutes for when you're
ready
hi thank you well good afternoon ladies
and gentlemen i'm sheila kirby and i
live at least so's on chapel hill
my property about globally the proposed
garages will have a severe impact on my
property and me personally
the proposal will have an overbearing
effect on my property due to the height
heightening extent of the building
the original planning consent stated
that the structure could only be visible
from the shared drive me
this is clearly not the case with the
latest proposal which is clearly clearly
demonstrated in the photographs i have
submitted
my photographs demonstrate that this
building will obstruct natural daylight
and block out the sun at certain times
of the day and year
the height of this
proposal will have a huge impact upon my
privacy and tranquility
as people on the roof terrace will be
able to clearly see into my living
accommodation and into my main garden to
the property and its seating area
my late husband
and i sorry
it's just staying on to this property 18
years ago
because it felt we felt it provided us
with a private
peaceful environment in which we could
live out until the end of our days
i trust the committee will ensure the
correct decision is made
so this remains the case for the welfare
of the community
which reside at chapel hill
thank you
thank you
have we got
pictures to be shown from mrs kirby
yes sir apologies i couldn't talk
i'm just going to see i don't i've got
pictures supplied by mr and mrs hardwick
mrs kirby's picture is the same one um
with the ladder from councillor miller
thank you okay
that's it
and i think this i think the next one as
well
that
yeah
that's from their window
okay yep thank you
okay are there any questions for mrs
kirby
thank you very much mrs kirby
thank you
and our last speaker on the objections
is mrs hardwick
hello mrs hardwick you have three
minutes when you're ready thank you
the reason for speaking today is not
personal it is to protect the area in
which we live
the use of the huge terrorists will
overlook and intrude on our privacy and
cause noise nuisance this is
demonstrated by my images
the garage roof terrace will be 45 foot
long and approximately 50 foot wide
the garage sticks out and is not teared
into the hillside at all
the hedge and wall on the lane side is
at present eight foot tall
this is nowhere near high enough to
screen the terrace at all it would take
years to grow the required height to
hide the terrace and people standing on
it
the suggested extra heist of the hedge
mentioned as a condition in the planning
officer's report is not enough
the terrorists will in effect be a huge
stage towering over the hedge and people
using it will look down into the gardens
of the neighbourhood neighbouring
properties
because of the sloping nature of the
hillside our garden is lower than
cloverley but our seating area is at the
top of our garden which is nearest to
cloverly
the sounds of people talking on the huge
patio will be funneled downwards to us
because we're lower than the terrorists
this has been demonstrated during
construction as we are able to hear
every word of the builder's
conversations and there is no escape
from their radio in our garden
this is beyond the normal noise
associated with neighbours due to the
fact that it will be projected from a
position so much higher than everyone
else the terrorist is large enough to
hold a very large party and would easily
accommodate all the paraphernalia
associated with gardens but as the roof
terrace is not at a normal garden height
and towers over everyone else this would
intrude into all the neighbours privacy
once built it will be there forever for
the applicant and any subsequent owner
to use as they see fit spoiling the
peace and privacy of the area the mature
trees have been removed which were
mentioned as screening the patio in the
first application
i'm concerned that if floodlit the patio
will destroy the dark skies that we
enjoy at the moment
the suggested
condition of a 1.5 metre high hedge
above the wall is nowhere near enough to
protect us from the noise and the fact
that we will all be overlooked 30
seconds remain
um i hope you'll consider my images and
the comments as this terrace will have
such a huge negative effect and impact
on the lives of the neighbours of
cloverleaf it's allowed to go ahead
thank you
thank you are there any questions for
mrs hardwick councillor armitage
uh thank you cheer uh yeah uh just one
question during the uh uh
adrian's uh address he said that uh
the there were no
windows overlooking this uh on your
property uh could you please confirm uh
the situation please uh yeah i was a bit
confused by that and the fact that it
said that that we've got no windows in
habitable rooms which i didn't
understand
we've got two small windows in the the
lounge that i'm sat in at the moment
that are above where we park our cars
which was shown on the picture which is
directly opposite
and on the lane we've actually got a
kitchen window as well
right and uh perhaps you could uh
remember the the noise factor you seem
to yeah
it's the noise the noise is the biggest
factor for us other neighbours are going
to be
far more troubled by being overlooked
the noise because in our garden there
has been no escape this this summer
during the first lockdown we weren't
able to go out in our garden due to the
noise
all right thank you very much
thank you
are there any further questions
thank you mrs hardwick
are there any questions for the planning
offices
chad there's another speaker yet oh
sorry um thank you mr mike whiteman
um
mr wakeman are you there
yes i'm here yes okay you have three
minutes mr whiteman
okay thank you
um the application steps permission to
reposition the garage by two meters this
was necessary due to adverse ground
conditions which meant we had to build a
separate wall which is what you can see
on the photographs
and that was because we had to show up
the ground around the house when we
excavated the garage
since brief submission to try and help
address the concerns that the neighbours
have put forward we've reduced the
height of the garage by half a meter
and the roof and parapet wall will step
down from the terrace
and there won't be we propose that
there's no access to the the first two
meters of roof
i believe that the already granted
permission that we have established that
this development does not contribute in
policy however
policy has been cited in some of the
objections which i think are invalid
we have very much respect the shape and
the form of the property
whilst developing significant
enhancements to it we've got skilled
stone masons working on the project with
english heritage experience we're using
reclaimed ambitious stone to clad all
visible parts of the garage where they
are not inset into the hill sorry
um we've got four adults living we'll
we'll have four adults living in the
property we've got four garage spaces uh
we think that's entirely appropriate
people have mentioned that it's it's
just two bigger developments
um but obviously with having space for
cars we're helping to avoid on-street
parking and in addition to that the
garage will house the plant room which
we have for the ground source heat pump
for the property
i don't believe that the the development
does adversely affect neighboring
properties because we've maintained
significant distances between the
development and the boundaries
it's three point meters away from the
nearest party wall with with lee's hose
which is a further four to five meters
away from that party wall and is set at
an angle away from cleveland
this other development is over two
meters away from the party wall which
the other side of that wall is um chapel
hill road itself and the nearest
property
um there is is touchstone
the view from the roof garden will
overlook cloverley's long garden down to
the shared access road which is over 17
meters away that access roads from the
development
no private gardens are overlooked
only at least those driveway touchstones
entrance gate area and other drivers can
be seen at the sides these are areas
that are already open to public view
either via chapel hill or by the access
road
we're retaining all party walls and
setting back the developments the garage
will remain under underground has been
structurally designed to take garden and
lawn on top we've taken great care to
ensure it blends into the surroundings
does not impose on neighbours and
protects our own privacy
diversion of watercourses onto chapel
hill has also been cited this is also
not true all runoff has been channeled
into a new connection to the public
training seconds remain which is as
approved by seven trends and we're also
using rainwater recycling systems which
will ultimately reduce the amount of
water that the property puts into the
into the public system
to summarize i think that we've breathed
new life into a very very tight property
we've taken the effort to source new
matching stones that property locally
from carlstage that's three minutes
chair we've got reclaimed derbyshire
stones and sure it blends beautifully
into the surroundings and we're using
traditional stone building methods with
new technology thank you mr wakeman
sustainability of the property
is there any questions for the speaker
councillor armitage
yes chia uh
presumably you you say you've had
ground conditions uh you've got problems
with them uh
did you have a surveyor do the job first
and check on these problems
yes we had a survey where a whole
topographical survey of the site before
before we started work but as you know
from seeing many
well if you watch grand designs you know
that there's always problems until you
get out of the ground and unfortunately
we have problems
yeah but i would have thought the survey
would have shown these up i mean we're
not talking grand designs here we're
talking about uh a garage in uh over
well the survey showed that the sort of
ground that we were dealing with
um which is which is mainly compacted
clay and sandstone
um
and then you know depending on the
weather conditions which we had
last last winter that's what really sets
us back quite considerably and we had to
to shore up the ground and put in that
um
that retaining wall which you see on the
photos
right uh
you've got four parking space for uh
room for four cars in the in the garage
it is a little bigger than that uh but
that's to do with the heat pump is it
well there's provision for the for the
for the plantary rest of the heat pump
that's correct yeah yeah
but don't you already own a garage
across the way
there is a small garage at the bottom of
the hill yes
right so
that's not um not really
very long or very very tall when you're
over six foot
so you you're in actual fact you've got
a garage in for five vehicles
and that's potentially true yes
right
thank you
are there any further questions for mr
rateman
no
thank you mr waitman
any questions now for planning offices
and i know councillor barry would like
to start the ball rolling
thank you chair um i think the only
question i've got really i mean looking
at the conditions that the officers have
already placed
on
the application is one to do with
lighting um i think if we could put
something in there that would restrict
any extra outdoor lighting so that it
you're not getting the air pollution the
same
um other than that i'm minded to go with
officers recommendations
[Music]
any other comments
for the officers councillor shipman
yeah i just wanted to wonder if one of
the officers just could clarify this is
the windows isn't the windows thing
because
we're obviously in a situation now where
where there's some residents here quite
rightly saying that they don't want to
be uh people looking through the windows
then officers telling us that there is
no windows so can we just stop some
clarity on that please alice
isn't one of your pictures shows the
cottage's opposite
yes if nicki is able to bring back the
presentation
yeah that would be it would be helpful
it would be useful to show a couple of
slides i think that
may help
um
it's
below there nikki
[Music]
the one showing the
the stone wall as you come up the road
it must be higher up possible
the first photo
the first photo of the photos
please
that one there that one yeah so there's
some
sorry
sorry there's that window there but that
looks
down the lane not onto the
um onto the applicant's site
and then if you can go and write to the
end mickey please one of the um
stakeholders photos
uh
which is not just a bit further
no up up up that one
that that shows
the
end elevation of that same cottage which
shows a brown door in it
but i can't see
what are those two windows on the left
there
their their touchstone
are they not being overlooked from this
standpoint i mean it looks they're not
they're not the ones that mrs hardwick
mentioned
mrs hardwick lives in the the property
with the with the brown door i believe
further to the right that one there
nikki yes with it with the windows at
alice has just discussed with you
council shipment
so i i
i am i'm also confused about the the
issue of the windows that mrs hardwick
mentioned did you mention the kitchen
window
there was two windows in in the living
room she said
well what's that property on the left of
this photo with the two with the two
windows there
that's where mr thomas lives i believe
that's that's touchstone
of course they're
higher up the hill and set
back from the uh the site boundary
can i just ask adrian um just the
clarification about
windows and about view and about light
am i right saying that they're not
actually a planning consideration
because of the distance away from the
property
certainly as far as far as officers are
concerned
our conclusion is that the
impact on neighboring windows is not
overriding in our view in terms of
impact from people standing or using the
patio area in whatever form in terms of
looking into those other other windows
that's that's not a concern that we
we've
expressed in our report and certainly as
alice has mentioned the windows further
down
the lane
don't look in our judgment onto the site
they look along the the shared access
way on to chapel hill itself
and those two windows that counts the
shipments just raised are set back from
the
back from the site and you can see that
on your on your papers in touchstone so
they're set back into the site
so that's not
up or an issue that we would raise
concerns about in in terms of the impact
on windows in lisos as as you've seen
you can look from those windows on lisos
to the patio but to gain a view into the
next door property of those windows from
the the patio area
would in my judgment be very difficult
both in terms of distance and the fact
you would be looking up into those
windows rather than looking down into
them and as as as you probably all know
if you look down
some somewhere it's much easier to gain
a view whereas if you're looking up it
is much more difficult because you're
looking into a dark area at the ceiling
normally so
so that wouldn't be our consideration
that we as officers would place
significant weight on i think that's
correct alice isn't it in our
consideration
um just just um i don't know if that
answers counselor barry's query but but
in terms of the noise and disturbance
which you've heard a lot about
unfortunately any development brings
with it
noise and disturbance and dust and
activity and deliveries etc and it
wouldn't normally be our consideration
to seek to restrict those on a
development of this size and scale on
larger developments yes we might but if
that was a concern of members
we could impose a condition that
restricted when and where
development could take place normally
that would be
excluding some days if that was an
overriding consideration of members
but although otherwise dos noise etc are
normally issues addressed by colleagues
in environmental health
thank you councillor reader then
councillor armitage
to sort of ask and alice and on the
picture that we've just seen that
council shipment was sort of asking the
questions about the two windows
is that the um where the hedge is going
to be replanted
can i just check that
is that where that hedge will be
replanted so it will offer the screening
sorry um those two windows i think that
one's touchstone isn't it um
that's where i was proposing that we
would condition that that hedge is re-uh
is replanted so yeah you can see it
there
um
yeah that that would it would be that
section
uh um
does it go all the way along and will it
scream
the two windows
would certainly scream the bottom window
i suppose possibly not so much the top
one um but that is that set quite far
back if you go to um nikki if you go up
to
um one of the photos a bit further up
um if you keep going up
uh
keep going sorry
a bit further
um
next one next one up i think
yeah um
or just
yeah no the next one up actually sorry
that one
that's taken from just outside the gate
of touchstone
so you can see that there's already
hedge
to the top of the wall that could be
thickened up
and then there's the gap but there was a
tree there i think um but that that was
where i was proposing that that would be
thickened up and and maintained at a
certain height
um
and we could i think i'm mindful to
agree with the gentleman that was
speaking earlier about this hedge and
and saying that you know it's not not
very good at the moment so i understand
what you're saying with regard to
thinking but i don't
like the gentleman was saying a little
bit higher so it offers that extra bit
of screening
yeah
yeah i think i mean we could
we can um
condition it at higher than i suggested
if i can add to that um
if if members were were and are
concerned about the issue of
the screening on one or either side of
the patio
another option of course would be to
require a screen wall or a screen fence
on the very edge of the patio area
itself which wouldn't then
require either the hedge to grow or be
awaited growing up to a certain height
you could impose a condition to that
effect but it would of course
increase the the built form of the
the patio the other thing that members
may wish to do in which we previously
discussed with the applicant is to
um
instead of having a wall right at the
end of his
two meter extended garage is to require
that wall to be two meters set back to
replicate exactly what has been approved
previously
and to condition that other two meters
isn't used as a patented balcony or
veranda so that would be another option
and then that would just leave
the area of usable patio exactly the
same
scale as that which has been previously
approved on the application
which um
didn't attract any objection or concern
at the time so that would be another
option we would need to
be careful in the way that we condition
that but that could also be done if the
issue of screening
was a particular concern to members and
you wish to restrict the active active
use of the patio to exactly the area
that was previously approved
the the issue that councillor barry
mentioned about lighting i didn't answer
that i apologize but yes if there were
was concern about lighting of the patio
area
then you could impose a condition
requiring a scheme of all external
lighting to be agreed by the council and
no other external lighting then to be
attached constructed or erected on the
on the feature on the building or the
garage however you want to describe it
excuse me
hopefully that helps chair
counts for armitage
yeah i think i think
uh the point that's been missed by
everybody is the fact that it's uh
the ground is falling away and if you
look at the picture the one with the
ladder
uh if we go back to that
it's going to stick out a long way and
it doesn't matter how high the head the
edge is
uh it's going to be something like four
and a half meters high
if we just uh
move that
there you are
and that's how high it is and if
somebody stands on top of that
how high do you want to hedge you know
if somebody it's
uh it's four and a half meters high
and uh somebody of two meters that's six
and a half meters somebody standing on
top of that parapet uh well you know
you're gonna have to have a quite a high
hedge to screen that far higher than
than you can see and this is the fact is
you've brought it forward the the out
the plan has been to bring it forward
and
it's going to cause the relocation
of this and as far as the garden's
concerned it's gonna go you know there
was isn't going to be much of a garden
he's asking for uh garaging for four
vehicles which is things are all right
well most detached houses only off for
two but there again
uh he seemed to be uh in favor of the
four
uh in spite of the fact that he has a
fifth garage
in another location at the end as far as
i'm concerned
uh it's it's looking
directly into the garden next door uh
the mrs kirby and it is greatly upset
her as you could tell
she's lived there all her life and this
is causing a great stress
and you've got to think about local
people
the massing is too great
it's against the uh it's not in
accordance with ap1
a b
d
and h it's against policy gs5 and local
plan h5 and it's been done uh all this
concrete was poured
far you know and as far as i was
concerned there was no plenty of
permission to move it but the base work
has been done
and uh it's a you know it's just
basically gone against all the plants
and
and it is a retrospective uh development
and if you can't see that well you know
i feel sorry for you quite frankly
i mean you know it's retrospective and
here we are another retrospective
adrian you want to come in yes a few
points if i if i may share that
hopefully help um we've had the
discussion about retrospective
applications earlier on this afternoon
the fact is a retrospective application
whether it is or not and i think i
disagree
um on the certainty of that with counter
armitage in this case but whether or not
it's a retrospective application you
need to consider it on its merits and
whether or not it's acceptable in terms
of comparison with your policies and any
other material matters
it's not been constructed and finished
so to my view this isn't fully a
retrospective application but it's
clearly the way that the building on
site is being constructed to conform
with what is proposed now in this
application rather than what has
previously been granted consent
listen adrian as far as i'm concerned
it's retrospective
until adrian's finished please i thought
he had i'm sorry
even so chad even if you believe that
the application in its current form or
in the current form proposed is not
acceptable you may wish to granted
consent subject to conditions which is
why i've suggested that
maybe warming either side of the patio
maybe having the front wall step back
two meters from the front of the
building and excluding use beyond that
to mirror what's been consented may well
address the concerns of members in
avoiding looking to either side of the
structure into other gardens or into
other windows potentially that may then
address that issue just in terms of the
photograph chair as i mentioned right at
the start
they are not photos that we as officers
have brought before you they're
photos that have been brought before you
by other stakeholders and therefore
you need to take them on their face but
the problem with photos annotated photos
in particular is they're 3d
and the photos that you've seen taken
from lisos towards the application site
showing the ladder is in 3d and the
structure is 3.5 meters
set back from the boundary with lysos
into the site so when you see it in 3d
in my opinion it's not as stark as that
photograph depicts
just in terms of that as well chair
alice will need to correct me if i'm
wrong here but with the parapet wall on
top of the structure that's the 4.5
meters that is being
referred to so that's not ground level
of the the structure that's taking into
account that parapet wall as well which
is approximately one meter in height i
think alice if that's correct so anyone
standing on that
additional bit of garage
would be
depending on the height of course
another 0.5 to perhaps 0.8 meters taller
than that so that's the context you need
to put it in but but again i come back
to the point that if members
are concerned about overlooking and
the impact on neighbours
you may feel that with the imposition of
conditions that we've discussed that may
address the concerns albeit it will
increase the bulk of the structure in
terms of those size because you would
normally be looking for walls or fences
at 1.8 meters
high
to
address any sideways looking so that's
another 0.8 meters on top of that wall
as that photo depicts albeit if you come
back 2 meters from the front of that
structure as permitted
then of course that length of
overlooking that the length of area of
overlooking would be reduced i do hope
that that helps you happy to answer any
further questions
thank you i could come back to you now
no
uh chair uh can i come back to adrian on
that yes
right uh
on this question of retrospective
when somebody digs footings in right uh
on a planning application uh
you will say that that applica that
they've started work
and this has had the footings put in and
concrete poured on so they have started
work
castle shipments shaking his head come
on
let's have you on me if you pave your
drive you've not started the development
it's the equivalent of that
if you there's certain things which
trigger a plan application that needs to
go in starting paving your drive is not
or concreting your drive is not a
starting point it's building the walls
you start building the walls and roofs
and the apartment applications started
no it's if you if you dig the trench to
put the footings in that's started
councillor barry needs to speak yeah i
think we've had a lot of discussion
around this um the only air you know and
i think we need to be moving on with
this application so i'd like to put the
motion forward that we go with office
recommendations and putting into that
the conditions that have been spoken
about about the hedging and about the
lighting um and i think we need to move
this policy
in that chair with the um conditions and
i think council shipments also nodding
yeah okay so for clarification then alan
before we take the vote
just need to clarification share if i
may on um the
uh
additional conditions that uh council
reader and councillor shipman and
council barry have mentioned chair
please and also if um members are minded
to to grant consent if that could be
words finalized delegated to myself in
consultation with yourself and counselor
barry chair thank you
so that effectively venture is to move
officer recommendations
with the uh specific um references
to hedging and lighting
um discussed at the meeting now with the
final wording to be agreed uh by the
planning development manager along with
yourself um vice sure
captured it members
i think there's always also the shaping
of the
balcony
and so the conditions on the shaping of
the balcony
yeah they're just a clarity on that
chair are you um
are you you asking for
i'm taking it that you're not asking for
walling or fencing on side of the
extended parapet as we've discussed but
are you now talking about
bringing the the front wall
back it to the two meter line precluding
any use beyond that
it's what you said before agent yes yeah
just so can be absolutely clear chad i
understand that now you don't want the
final two meters
to be used as balcony parapet or veranda
you want the
limit to be to the extent as previously
approved i understand that bit just need
clarity check that members aren't voting
on the provision of any wall or screen
fencing either side of the patio just
relying on that condition that alice has
discussed about allowing the hedge to
grow to an appropriate level yes
yeah that's that's on both sides adrian
so
both residents either side or obviously
their concerns can be dealt with yeah
but it's a green finish rather than a
hard
stone or fence finish thank you
so the motion would be then um to
go with officer recommendations subject
to those conditions
yes that's fine is nikki ready for a
roll call
thank you chair so the motion stands to
to approve with conditions if you
clearly say fall against or abstain
counsel armitage
against
cancer barry or
counselor cooper
or
counselor huckabee
for
cancer pots
or
cancer powell
cancer reader or
casa rouse
or
councillor ruff or
council shipment
four
chair i make that
eight votes for two against with zero
abstentions which means uh that motion
has been carried
thank you thank you all for that
moving on to item five planning appeals
lodged and determined
over tuesday
i don't wish to um prolong members
attendance this afternoon beyond
that which you wish chair so i'll just
very briefly make reference
and ask members to take particular note
of the fourth
appeal dismissed
which is the land allocation limited
appeal and it is a very interesting
appeal on a number of aspects chair
in that the the inspector in that appeal
has taken a different tack
to a number of inspectors previously in
terms of what he considered with a
basket of most appropriate policies
input in reference to the the
determination of the appeal
he concluded that the basket of policies
led him to place weight on the
development plan in that respect that
they conformed to the mppf
and
importantly chair he concluded that the
tilted balance so-called tilted balance
wasn't
um activated which is in contrast to the
the conclusions that the inspector of
the tip shelf road home would appeal in
stark contrast to that
it does chair and
members will perhaps have no sympathy
with me on this aspect but it does make
it difficult for us as officers to
give clear guidance to to you as members
because there doesn't seem to be any
consistent path coming forward from
inspectors who
should all undertake the same training
and have the same knowledge as one
another
but
obviously we will continue to try and uh
and help members on on that but i think
what one thing it does suggest is that
where you have these
large-scale housing developments you
need to be quite clinical in the
evaluation of the policies that you have
both in your extant local planet
hopefully soon in a in an adopted plan
that will replace that and clinically
assess which policies you're taking into
account and the weight you attach to
them with evidence as necessary to
support them in terms of land
allocations chair as you know we
required a team of um
people to support the council in that
and there was good evidence provided by
the landscape architect mr jeff cox so
again i think um
having that
investment in that expertise paid
dividends in this respect jen we will
need to do that in the future in
advising you the other thing just to
bear in mind i'm sure this won't have
been lost on members who've read the
appeal decision was the conclusion that
the inspector came to on highway safety
grounds
and uh i'll i'll leave members perhaps
to review the appeal decision and
come to your own view on that as you
know as officers we
take on board the advice of the uh the
county council
but it does suggest that again um which
we try and do as officers honestly i i
can say honestly we do and we try and
evaluate what's said to us but as you
know in for the most part we go with
the highway authority but it does show
that
um
you need to take and evaluate that but
i come back chair to the issue i always
make to to members is that we were able
to put forward evidence to the inquiry
from the
gentleman that we asked to provide that
evidence to us so that advice still
pertains that we need to have evidence
but perhaps in the future if members are
concerned about highway safety advice
that we're getting
and it is you feel absolutely integral
to your decision and you're not happy
with the highway advice that we've got
the possibility of getting independent
advice before you make your decision
maybe something you would wish to
consider
down the line so just those those
elements general than that we're
his officers very
pleased with the the decisions that we
received this last month um certainly
the one in respect to the list we get to
kill the marsh which which you're very
pleased the inspector supporters on
board but certainly the land allocation
one and two um to a lesser extent the
others but mr mrs theresa's it was was
interesting as well in terms of the
issues that were raised there but
certainly land allocations does just
warrant a second reading if um if you
already read it and in the first reading
if you've not had the chance to do so
thank you i could take any questions
i've known members have had a long
afternoon so i don't want to to keep
members here unnecessarily are there any
questions
jolly good thank you everybody i
appreciate it's been a really long
afternoon thank you very much i wish you
all a happy christmas and new year and
i'll see you then there's no urgent
business chair so thank you thank you
you